[Music]
and looking forward to this for a while
so thank you for coming on the show I
appreciate it
now the pleasures pleasures all mine and
congrats on this book I mean this is
quite an accomplishment and it's no
surprise that it's resonating with so
many people right now I appreciate that
very different project for me so I was
nervous about the reception yeah it is
it seems like it isn't it isn't I mean
it in many ways it's an extrapolation of
your previous book absolutely absolutely
I mean it right if you look at like the
afterword of the last book which I sort
of came out of a debate with Malcolm
Gladwell I was writing for that sort of
an expanded version of that basically
becomes the intro yeah it sets the stage
for every unit you explore in this book
and perhaps that's a good launching off
point here to kind of contextualise what
we're gonna talk about like and it's
such a great story I mean you got to
tell the Malcolm Gladwell debate story
okay so many times men but it isn't I
mean and these are so after the
publication my first book this morning
we were invited to the MIT Sloan Sports
analytics conference which is co-founded
by the general manager of the Rockets
and we were invited there to debate like
10,000 hours versus the sports team even
though we had you know middle ground but
that that's I was set up and I'd never
met him before right and and he was too
busy to like participate in any of the
pre event calls so I had like no idea
what any super clever and so like I
didn't want to get steamrolled you know
you're gonna double down on getting
ready for this right right and so in
prepping I sort of tried to anticipate
the things that that he might argue and
knew that he would have to argue for
early specialization in in deliberate
practice and so I said okay well I'm the
science writer and Sports Illustrated
let me go look at what the literature
says if it's compatible with that my
hypothesis can you sell across most
sports athletes going to become elite
have this sampling period where they try
a variety of things they gain he's sort
of broader skills importantly they learn
about their own interests and abilities
and delay specializing until later than
their peers and so you know on stage is
sort of talked about that and we sort of
contrasted as the Roger vs. tiger model
because Roger Federer played a bunch of
different sports and Tiger was early
specialization
and after we came off the stage he sort
of said you know what you got me on was
that like Roger verse Tiger thing and we
ended up becoming running buddy you see
invites me the next day to go do some
intervals with him and he was like a
Canadian provincial champ in the 1500
meters he's quietly this extraordinary
runner yeah and he's like the biggest
sand bagger in the world I talked to him
recently and he's like I'm like you're
running again to be having a knee
problem and he says I'm at the point
where I can run for a minute without
pain so I'm just doing a minute and then
I see like a week later pictures on
Twitter of him doing intervals like at a
trap and I'm like you say he's such a
yes got to be ready for the workout
what's it like to go running with him
it's great I mean it's he's he if
anything I would say he needs to learn
how to back off sometimes like when he
gets the intervals he hits them really
hard and and sometimes like all the way
up to his races a little bit so huh so
my like sort of contribution to his
training was like you're 12 days out in
your big race like don't sweat session
yeah yeah but but it's great it's a lot
of fun and then so then we would talk
about this stuff on our own time and to
my delight you know I sort of found it
he didn't view our ideas as being like
this zero-sum competition but more like
let's talk about it and learn stuff from
each other and that was like a great
kind of model for me it's really cool
and what I appreciate about that is his
malleability like his openness to new
ideas and his willingness to say yeah I
was a little bit maybe not entirely
wrong but there are certain things that
David brought up that I was wrong about
and I will happily admit that and do so
in a blur for your humor you look you
know yeah I love that that blur but and
so in we were invited back to the Sloan
Sports animal news conference in March
and you know I'm the this one's also on
YouTube and at the end of the video he
says like I now feel that I conflated
two ideas the the fact that it takes a
lot of practice to become good in
something with the idea that that
implies that to be good at X you should
do only X from as early as possible I
thought that was like a great way to
update the mental model that's cool I
was thinking about this earlier today
and it occurred to me that on some level
it seems that it depends on how you
define that 10,000 hours it's like how
how broad is the scope of the work right
like if you if you're very specific
about that
yes your argument prevails but if you
take a broader view of what it means to
put in that 10,000 hours and what those
disciplines entail then your ideas kind
of dovetail into each other totally and
in many ways I mean you're getting at
the heart of some of what I was
wrestling with here right because as
I've looked sort of when I started
interacting with the so-called 10,000
hours literature the deliberate practice
framework for my last book he would see
things that said you know that denied
that right that even doing waits for a
golfer didn't count as deliberate
practice because it wasn't golf or
trying these other things didn't matter
and that there was no kind of natural
proclivities for things you should just
pick something for someone and just put
them on that path and over time I think
that definition of deliberate practice
has gotten it's sort of broadened
sometimes to such a degree that it looks
like it's only what in retrospect did
cause someone to improve at which point
you don't have so much of a scientific
hypothesis but but if if my contribution
would be broadening that definition the
way people think about it I think that'd
be a great contribution right if you
look at the work that goes into you
putting a book like this together as
I've heard you say like you read you
know thousands of these studies and many
of which seem irrelevant or don't you
know directly inform what ends up on the
page but yeah that's part of the 10,000
hours right and and maybe that study
that you dismissed or wasn't appropriate
for this book has a second life and
something else that you write you know
ten years later totally and and also in
I mean that's part of this like I used
to kind of chastise myself for being
inefficient because I would end up
reading so much stuff that didn't you
know I'd go down some rabbit hole and
come up a week later and say how did I
ever think I was gonna write about that
but now I realize that that sort of
searching requires some inefficiency and
that's sort of how I find the things and
connect all these things and sort of
know the arguments that they will be out
there too because I'm aware of the
literature even that I didn't put in the
book based right on some level you're a
product of your thesis in the book like
you're you're somebody who is an example
of a generalist who found their way by
dabbling in many different things and
sampling to use your language how much
of that is in the back of your mind when
you're writing this book like
I'm gonna self justified my own
trajectory ya know it's I mean I think
to some degree both of like my first
book was my own questions about like the
interplay of nature and nurture from
being an athlete and from being a
spectator right and in this in this case
I didn't initially like realize that
much that I was sort of kind of
investigating my own path a little bit
because the spark came from this debate
with Gladwell and his interactions I had
with the Pat Tillman Foundation and so
those career changers there and sort of
as it went along as particularly when I
got to this thing called the Dark Horse
project where I was interviewing the
researchers and they're like by the way
would you like to become a subject
because like obviously you know you're
just like the people were studying these
sort of career zig zag errs so sort of
like partway through when I kind of
realized like this feels so relevant and
I don't know how much of that was sort
of implicitly in my mind but that's when
it became sort of explicit when I came
to that the dark or those researchers
who study how people find match quality
you know the degree of fit between what
they do and who they are mm-hmm yeah I
mean you're somebody who you studied
environmental science and astronomy yeah
yeah Columbia yeah
which is a you know a bizarre choice for
somebody who ends up writing for Sports
Illustrated yes yes well I've gotten
like almost I would say like linearly
less tied to long term goals I've gotten
older like when I was a teenager I was
sure I was gonna go to the Air Force
Academy and be a test pilot and be an
astronaut and of course I didn't do any
of those things and I end up studying
you know geology and environmental
science and astronomy and I was living
in a tent in the Arctic when I decided
for sure I was gonna try to become a
writer and at a time I only felt sort of
behind I didn't realize that when I
entered Sports Illustrated as a temp
fact checker like a number of years
behind people at the same level or even
at higher levels but it turned out that
this my very ordinary science skills
taken from this area became suddenly
extraordinary at Sports Illustrated
we're kind of merging those I didn't
have to be in zero-sum competition with
everyone waiting in line to be like the
next NFL beat reporter I can just do my
own thing and compete against myself and
if I could do that well enough like I
could have a role that's so interesting
and and your athletic career trajectory
also informs the same idea yeah I very
much had a sampling period football
basketball baseball you know the people
that did watch this on video though they
won't be surprised that I didn't make
the NBA
you know because I'm a small guy but I
started to realize you know I actually
did I got injured once and decided to
run to like stay in shape for other
sports mm-hmm and kind of like started
getting addicted to it you know you
start to feel that improvement I wasn't
even I wasn't good I was bad but I was
improving and so I decided I just keep
one one to keep doing that I started in
college as a walk-on was like literally
the worst person on the team I got
paired with a guy who was when we were
both juniors in high school he was 20
seconds faster and I wasn't 800 meter
right like that's like embarrassing if
you saw those yeah yeah you're you're
not exaggerating I mean in the book
you're like no I was literally the
slowest like the coaches felt sorry for
you yeah yeah that's why yeah coach gave
a pep talk one story I was kind of like
man he used to be painful to watch it
and like I guess that's cool but I'm I
was sort of like that that was a weird
way to give a pep talk but but it so it
it led to this stuff like you know I won
the award of Columbia for the athlete
who achieved significant athletic
success in the face of unusual challenge
and difficult my challenge and
difficulty just being that I was
terrible yeah Hurst right but the good
thing about being a walk-on was you know
I was paired with this guy who was
already like a Canadian national level
runner for training and he already had
all these expectations and he had to
score for the team and all this sort of
stuff whereas I I nobody cared what I
was doing or if I was scoring so for the
first two years I could just blow you
know my results just trying to find a
type of training that worked for me
uh-huh and then when I hit that I like
took off like rocket fuel right and
right flew by him and like he never beat
me again I ended as a university record
holder and all these things but I think
it was a blessing in disguise that I got
to have those first two years to
experiment with myself because nobody
cared
uh-huh if I how I contribute it right
right all right yeah I mean it's
impossible for me to read your book and
not reflect on you know the choices that
I've made throughout my life and and my
own you know kind of strange career
trajectory and I'm somebody who you live
in DC right like I grew up in DC was
terrible at all sports found my way to
swimming and it was the one thing that I
felt like I had some some low level of
innate talent and I just gravitated
towards that and very quickly
specialized in in this and just kind of
doubled down and that was my lane
this is an era in which on some level we
I think the philosophy at the time at
least with respect to this sport was
kind of inherited from you know Soviet
you know camp systems in terms of like
how to develop an athlete and there was
a lot of pressure at a young age to
start doing double workouts and you know
I was a little bit later to that and
some of my peers but at 15 you know I
was doing three or four hours of
training every single day six days a
week and I'm a successful product of
that system
but also I now in retrospect looking
back realize like how limiting it was in
terms of my overall development not just
as an athlete but as a human being
because it crowded out any space or time
to really explore other things yeah and
I mean at least what I've incorrect me
if I'm wrong what I've read about you
yet a little bit of exploration before
that where you tried these other sports
and realize they weren't a good right
and you haven't found something right so
you had some sampling period early a
little bit right that it's nothing to
know immediately that I was bad right
but that's important right you can't
Intuit that stuff like you have to try
it and reflect on it and and then it
seems to me like you sort of continued
that that sense of a sampling period
like later in life I think the things
that you've ended up doing is same for
me my most important projects are never
things that I saw coming in fact when I
was listening to maybe like a year ago a
podcast you and Julie put up from one of
your retreats it seemed like almost all
the questions people were asking you
were how do I figure out what I should
be doing like some form of how do I
figure out what I should be doing or how
do I know and so you know I think that
that sampling period that you can be
limited in a way that like precludes you
from finding your match quality right
like one of the quotes I loved in the in
the book that stuck with me because I
don't know what I'm going to do next
right but I'm not as like agitated about
that as I used to be was from this woman
Herminia Ibarra who studies how people
make successful career changes and she
said we learned who we are in practice
not in theory right and what she means
by that is she's you know marshaled all
this psychology research to show that
we're not as good as we think at just
like introspecting and understanding
what will make us feel fulfilled what
we're good at what we're interested in
we actually have to try things then
reflect on it in like a very you know
deep way if you can't like actually take
some real time for reflection then keep
zigzagging right there's so much code
sort of social and cultural pressure
that pushes up against that though for
sure we have all these you know
judgments about what it means to walk
away from something or to quit something
yeah and it impedes our ability to
sample on that level yeah no definitely
and I think that's why one of the things
that really again resonated with me
about Herminia Barros work was she says
you know we think of we think you know
you you're pressured not to change and
you develop a new interest a lot of
you're kind of confidants say like you
know don't get off-track don't get
behind and it's a really hard thing to
do because it requires changing your
identity especially if you're really you
know what you've done is a big part of
yourself you don't change your identity
overnight you have to sort of start with
these little keyhole experiments until
something that you think was just an
interest becomes like a real passion or
a vocation right yeah you talk about the
sunk cost mentality yeah right where
it's like I can't walk away from this
like I experience that with being a
lawyer it's like I went to law school I
incurred law school loans my parents
helped me out like I can't walk away
from this I've invested way too much in
this what would that mean to my identity
and all the other people that supported
me and everything that went into this
yeah no and the Sun cost is so strong
right there was one in Inventor in range
named Jerry Seth who became extremely
successful and what I thought was really
interesting was she said when she
started her her master's program she
didn't like she realized like after a
year she didn't like what she was
studying like some area of Materials
Science and so she wanted to switch and
she was told like don't switch you'll
get behind right she's like one year
into a 50 year working life and they're
saying don't switch she'll get behind
then she does her PhD decides she's not
really into that either decides to
switch when she goes into professional
world and again they're like this is you
know disaster for you but you're a
dilettante right she goes to 3m and
realizes that that sort of sense of
insecurity forces her to like interview
tons of her colleagues she learns what
they all do and suddenly she knows all
this like adjacent stuff to what she
does and can assemble these teams of
people who become incredibly productive
and she becomes one of their most
decorated scientists ever but if she had
listened you know about being one year
behind and how long is your so I think
that the trade-off for finding a better
match with like a little bit of
experiment
in time there's like almost you know no
question yeah well we live in a in
interesting times where there's this you
know where it seems like across the
board and all disciplines everything is
becoming more and more specialized yeah
you don't go to medical school to just
become a doctor you have to find some
very you know detailed niche right and
you're you know education and experience
is very structured and limited to that
one thing just because you went to
medical school if you're whether you're
an anesthesiologist or you know you're
working in a lab or whatever like you're
the expansiveness of what you understand
and study and experience on a day to day
basis is very limited and it's almost
like if you look at cell biology like we
started as single-cell organisms and
become increasingly more and more
complex and if you look at planet Earth
we start with you know hunter-gatherer
societies and then villages and these
cities that when you're flying on an
airplane you look down on them look like
biological organisms where every tiny
human being plays one very discrete
specialized part in that and your book
is really a call to it's almost like
this this call to go back to the way
that we were in in not just a
renaissance way but even all the way
back to the beginning where man had to
learn lots of things in order to just
simply survive and now we've kind of
lost our connection with that and
survival means being very good at one
very limited thing and yet now we're in
a time where with AI and the you know
tech innovations that we're seeing that
we really need to be more generalized in
our approach to our lives yeah I mean
you hit on a number of I think like
deeply profound things there so to go to
sort of the first one in medicine right
we're now it's super specialized and
that specialization has been inevitable
and beneficial in some ways but like a
cardiologist used to be specialized now
to be specialized a cardiologist has to
work at let's say on only cardiac valves
you know the little floppy doors that
let blood in and out of the heart and
that specialization has forced those
practitioners to use what's called
surrogate markers where instead of
looking at the body the organism
right they treat one tiny thing that
they assume is a proxy for the outcome
that they want and so that cardiologist
might do something to alter the cardiac
valve but what you really care about is
if people die from a heart attack or
stroke at different rates
right and it turns out in many cases we
treat these little surrogate markers and
then when you zoom out and look at what
people actually care about it's made no
difference right they a die of heart
attack and stroke at the same rate with
a different cardiac valve or with lower
blood pressure numbers or whatever and
so this sort of reductionism that we've
applied to the body which is clearly a
system right you mentioned single cells
we know a lot about how cells work and
yet like we're not even close to being
able to brick the type of poetry that a
person who's just made up of cells will
right and so I think sort of a lack of
recognition of how important the system
the emergent properties of the system
are has led to these sort of perverse
effects right in medicine where so it's
like and once one of the studies I cite
in has now just been replicated where if
you were checked in for certain cardiac
problems into a hospital you're less
likely to die if it's during the dates
of a national cardiology conference that
it's so amazing and counterintuitive
right and Mollica when all the all the
cardiologists are at the conference
that's when you want to go in for your
procedure right and you're well and
you're less you're less likely to you
actually get some of the procedures that
have low evidence levels right that the
most specialized so the specialized
surgeons do have fewer complications
when they do a procedure but they also
do the procedures in many many cases
when they're not helpful basically and
you know to accredit one of the
cardiologists a cardiologist wrote an
editorial about that study saying my
colleagues now used to joke that this
conference would be like the safest way
to have safest place to have a heart
problem in the world and this has really
turned that on its head and we need to
like do some inflection yeah the
analogous example is that of the airline
crews that when they're when they're new
and haven't worked together that's when
you're right for the bad things to
happen yeah yeah so it was like some 77%
of commercial air problems occur on a
cruise first day of working together and
and mostly on their first flight right
because if things go as planned there's
very well known and appropriately
specialized roles for a flight crew
the problem is when their training is to
sort of repetitive basically which I
would say in some ways fits like one of
the original definitions of normal
practice
they lose the ability to improvise and
they will stick to those those practices
that they've learned that it become
automatic even when to like an outside
observer who doesn't even know anything
it becomes like ridiculous to drive it
yeah you become very rigid in your
processes and and thinking patterns yeah
yeah and there's this one of the sort of
a summary one of the the researchers in
range I interviewed sort of summarized a
body of work for me about
problem-solving in a way that I thought
was very eloquent she said basically
amounts to breath of training predicts
breath of transfer transfer being your
ability to take your skills and
knowledge and apply them to a new
problem that you haven't quite seen so
or something unexpected happens and
breath of training is the diversity of
the problem types that you face in
training will predict your ability to do
that and if if you're facing sort of a
narrow range of problem types then
you'll learn what's called using
procedures knowledge where you learn how
to execute something really well if
you're facing this incredible diversity
you learn this more making connections
knowledge where you're learning how to
match a strategy to a type of problem
and that's the kind of knowledge you
need when it comes to improvising right
one of the really interesting things
that you explore is this difference
between kind and wicked environments
which kind of informs the the federer
you know woods example that opens the
book so explain that yeah so so these
are terms coined by the psychologist
Robin Hogarth in a kind learning
environments one of the reasons I use
golf is it's an example of like the
epitome of a kind learning environment
which is all the informations available
next steps are clear goals are clear
patterns repeat rules never change and
when you do something you get automatic
feedback that is both immediate and
fully accurate so in kind learning
environments basically by doing
something and being cognitively engaged
you get better just with experience on
the other end of the spectrum are wicked
learning environments where all the
information may not be clear human
behaviors often involved people may not
be waiting for each other take turns the
next steps may not be clear rules may
change patterns may not repeat you may
or may not get feedback it may not be
automatic may be delayed it may be
inaccurate in some cases it may even
teach you the wrong lesson so one of
Hogarth's examples of a very wicked
learning environment was this New York
City physician who
would palpate patients tongues like feel
around their tongue with his hands
uh-huh and by doing that he could
predict weeks before they showed a
single symptom that they would develop
typhoid like over and over and he became
incredibly prominent for doing this and
as one of his colleagues later observed
using only his hands he was a more
productive carrier of typhoid than even
typhoid mary so he was transferring it
to these patients tongue right his hands
and so his accurate predictions were
reinforcing the exact wrong lesson and
so that's that's a really wicked
learning environment when the feedback
enforces the wrong lesson we're not you
know most of us aren't in that wicked of
an environment
either but the work that we do is kind
of increasingly the kind world stuff can
be is what AI is taking over and right
the wicked world where we can't count on
repetitive patterns is where most of us
are are operating or will be forced out
yeah where the variables are innumerable
and the dynamic is always shifting and
you can't you just can't control the
environment in the way that you can for
example with a golf swing yeah right
yeah and I mean Hogarth's oh-ho God said
it pretty early in the book so tennis is
more dynamic than golf right the
patterns change a little bit the game
speeds up as you get to higher levels
these things like that but even that I
sort of had to move on from because
Oakheart specifically talks about tennis
which was totally surprised me but he
says you know most of us are actually in
the work that's most important for us
playing Martian tennis where you see
people doing stuff but nobody's told you
the rules it's up to you to deduce them
and they could change any time without
notice yeah that's interesting
coaching is it is a big part of this as
well like you if you have in sports it's
very it's very binary right like there's
an athlete and there's a coach and the
coach is always there to provide
feedback so adjustments are always being
made but then we go out into the world
and do whatever we do and we're not in a
situation or an environment where we're
getting that kind of constant feedback
so that we can make those kinds of
adjustments so talk a little bit about
how that plays out in your thesis yeah
and even if we do have those coaches
most of us aren't in that sort of
zero-sum sports world right so one of
the things I realized after my first
book after I started to my surprise
getting invited to like these sort of
more general
performance conferences not just sports
was that sometimes I felt we were making
poor extrapolations from sports in
certain ways because sports are zero-sum
and they're very easily quantifiable and
the feedback is eard it easier to give
in a lot of ways or to perceive in many
cases just automatic to what you're
doing in the wider world that's not
necessarily the case right so even
having a coach which i think is valuable
you you know you're not gonna be able to
expect perfect feedback but I do think
it can help a lot so one of the I'm like
I'm a new parent for example and I've
been getting a lot of questions I wasn't
like trying to write for parents so much
this is a parenting book in many ways
that's something I definitely want to
talk to you about so I'm starting to
realize but yeah and so people are like
asking me for parenting advice I'm like
well with my four months of experience
let me tell you how it goes and and so
what I've sort of started to think of my
role as like combining the the things
from this book where say okay you
learned who you are in practice not in
theory you have to search for your match
quality zigzag and and then you end up
still in kind of a wicked world there's
something I mentioned sort of briefly
called talent based branching that the
army started using when they were having
problems with her tension and they had
this strict sort of upper out structure
for people's careers for their high
potential future officers and that
wasn't really working with retention and
it started not working primarily like
since like the 90s basically and so they
first they throw money at people and the
people are gonna stay took it people are
gonna leave left anyway right half a
billion dollars of taxpayer money down
the drain so they start other programs
like one called talent based branching
where they say okay instead of saying
here's your career track go up or out
they say we're gonna pair you with a
coach here are some possible career
tracks try one the coach will help you
reflect on how that fits your interests
and talents what else is available then
try another and another and another and
you'll keep sort of triangulating what's
a good fit for you and that turned out
to be a great retention strategy for
them I think because match quality is so
important to us that even more than
money getting someone in doing something
that that emphasizes their talents and
their interest is so important so I view
my role as a parent it's kind of you
know other than keeping them alive and
all that stuff if the details is as like
that coach in the talent brace
processor I say can i facilitate a lot
of opportunities for you to try and then
sort of help you reflect because you
have to do that proactively that
reflection that doesn't just happen so
it's like a prime trait of so-called
self regulatory learners who end up
learning a lot about themselves you have
to actually like proactively do it and
then help him reflect on those
experiences so he takes the maximum
amount of signal and learning from each
one of the experiences so that's sort of
how I conceived my role
yeah I mean you as a parent of four kids
like it's always been it's not because
I've read a parenting book
it just seemed it just seemed obvious to
me that the the job is to expose them to
as many things as possible and then pay
close attention to what they gravitate
towards what they naturally seem to be
inclined to do and then fill the gap
like show up and support that and then
be neutral like if they decide I don't
want to do that anymore like that's okay
you know I grew up in an environment
where where you know grit and
perseverance took center stage and it
was like no you stay in it and as
successful as you know that made me in
certain respects like I said earlier it
limited me and so I my whole thing is
like I'm not emotionally attached right
like let's just pay attention do this do
this do this and and just notice and be
okay with whatever the kid decides they
want to do or don't want to do yeah I
mean but that feels like it's not nearly
as clean advice as like pick the thing
for them right right and I do think it's
important to note that we are like the
Tiger Woods stories probably the most
impactful development story you know in
modern writing and the Mozart is also
write a big one but I think as I was
sort of looking into those I think we're
telling them a little bit wrong like
Tiger has said my father never asked me
to play golf
never it was the child's interest in
matters not the father's yeah his dad
didn't have to say that right because
there's actions spoke louder than
whatever came out of his mouth exactly
and I looked back at some of like
Mozart's letter and there's I found
these accounts where musicians came over
and visited his house when he was a kid
and Mozart wants to play with them he
wants to play violin second violin and
his father says like you've not taken
any lessons go away you can't play and
he starts crying and so one of the other
musicians goes in another room with him
and says I'll play with him so he stops
crying and
here second violin part coming from the
other room and they come in and watch
and little Wolfgang's playing and that
the letter says his translated letter
says little wolfgang was so emboldened
by our applause to insist that he could
also play the first violin and so then
he goes and play and then that's when
his father starts responding to this and
creating you know all these
opportunities so I don't think we have
to be worried about missing Tiger and
Mozart as rare as those people are I
think you still have a better chance if
you expose them to a bunch of stuff and
maybe one of those things catches fire
but they're not like father manufactured
they were facilitated once they showed
this intense an unusual interest mm-hmm
yeah I mean the other thing with that
approach I mean every parent wants to
think that their kid is a genius there's
you know Mozart or Tiger or whatnot I
mean these things are so rare and what
happens more often than not is even in
the instance of great talent you end up
with a Todd Marinovich or you know an
Andre Agassi even in the most successful
test case there are all these
psychological problems that manifest
later in life and we've seen this with
Tiger you know even in the best example
being Tiger he has this crisis you know
at this stage in his life because you
know I mean just as an armchair
psychologist looking at that it's like
he has all he's not he has a childhood
trauma he's got all these unresolved
issues and he's been in this very narrow
lane for so long he hasn't fully
developed as a human being and at some
point you know the explosion becomes
inevitable yeah yeah and so I think
maybe he had to do some of that that
growing that you would normally hope to
do a little bit earlier you know under a
public stage yeah so he's done it and
now he's come back but you know you see
with Michael Phelps as well you know the
same thing and the great sort of
comeback but as a whole human being
because that pause had to occur in order
for the maturation to take place yeah
and I think that's important thing to
keep in mind like we our whole humming
whole human beings right and and we know
even if we just restricted to
athleticism we know like the way to
develop the best ten-year-old athlete in
most sports is not the same as the way
to develop the best 20 year old athlete
and I think that's sort of a decent
analogy for the whole person which is
the way to to optimize the things the
goals that are being set for kids is not
the same ways to optimize their
long-term development
I mean that's really one of the
underlying themes of the whole book
whether it's like learning math sports
or sort of developing interests is that
the things that you can do to cause the
apparent most rapid short-term success
can sometimes undermine your right yeah
that's that's really the core message of
the whole thing yeah like do you want
the immediate satisfaction of rapid you
know progress early in life or are you
looking to set someone up for long term
success yeah and I have to say I found
that deeply very deeply counterintuitive
right because I was very like
achievement oriented when I was young
too so it was definitely something I
sort of wrestled with convincing my yeah
well the best example my favorite
example in the book is van Gogh
I mean it just goes on and on and on
with all the things that this guy was
trying to do before he kind of found his
thing
yeah and talk about grit right he had
this increase top that he goes on the
people around him comment on his work
ethic so he's first this great student
at a boarding school he doesn't like
living away from home so he drops out
and he's an art dealer and he writes his
uncle had this fabulously successful art
dealership and gives him a job he writes
his parent says I'll never have to look
for work again you know pretty soon he
has disagreements with his boss he gets
laid off then he goes to be a teacher
kind of likes that but doesn't totally
work out decides to be a pastor
following father's footsteps he makes a
hat with lights on it so he can stay up
later like with candles and then read
later than his peers and get up earlier
than them and he copies whole texts by
hand and he keeps saying like you know
my advantage will be my work ethic but
like Latin and Greek aren't coming
easily to him and he leaves that and he
keeps bouncing around becomes a
bookseller and there his his colleagues
left records where of his endurance
again where when the bookstore flooded
he like saved a lot of the store by just
carrying arm loads of books by hand
hours and hours and he bounces between
being a then a pastor then he kind of
fails out of that and a catechist was
just kind of itinerant unlicensed
feature in the coal country you know
this area where the workers are so
downtrodden they refer to ground level
is up there in hell above the mine and
he flames out at pretty much everything
he's living in the coal country has no
possessions no achievements he's coming
up you know and being 30 years old and
decides to like try to document the life
around him buys a book called the guide
to the ABCs of Troy
and start sort of trying to draw the
life around him isn't that good at first
but sort of likes it and realizes when
he turns his gaze on nature he's got
something there mm-hmm sort of tries to
learn watercolors doesn't work the guy
listed on his Wikipedia page for his
education is like a cousin that he spent
three weeks trying to study watercolors
with before the cousin was like you
don't have a delicate enough hand and
he's been told early in life that he
wasn't a good drawer I didn't do it well
even I mean early on when he was 33 I
think he got he tried to take a formal
course because his brother basically
said like you have to try some real
training I'm not gonna send you money
anymore uh-huh and he finishes last in
the class competition and and is told to
go down to a class with ten year olds
right but he keeps bouncing between
these experiments and one day he takes
some oil paints out to a beach and a
storm it's getting sandblasted he has to
run in and out of cover and slap paint
on this first oil painting slap paint on
the canvas and that sort of riddim of
this crippling perfectionism where he's
going really slow and he and the next
letter to his brother says painting has
turned out to be easier than I expected
uh-huh and then he continues to pinball
from one experiment to another until he
sort of merges all those experiments in
the last two years of his life and just
you know becomes disruption on a massive
scale anyway changes what artists do
from thence forth it's like the bridge
between from realism to a to modern art
and you know he uh so the interesting
kind of case study of grit or not
because he would he worked so hard at
everything he did but then he would also
end up like quitting these things until
he found a fit for himself uh-huh
almost the the perfect combination of
grit and the ability to let go yeah yes
I think you know in range I talk a
little bit about this economist who sort
of modeled the way to find your match
quality in the world and it's very much
like van Gogh so I sort of described him
as this match quality searching
algorithm where you dive into something
and try to get as much signal as you can
and so van Gogh would do that because
he'd dive into everything so
wholeheartedly which meant it was all
and difficult for him but he would get a
very quick signal about if it fit him
and then you keep zigzagging until you
until you find sort of the thing where
you can uniquely feel fulfilled so some
some aspect of what you write about is
is an unraveling of Angela Duckworth
work with grit I mean you
recognized the importance of it but also
you kind of unravel her thesis a little
bit and you know her book has been so
fundamental and instrumental in
informing you know professional lives
and it's so heralded so explain a little
bit about where where you kind of fall
on grit yeah and again I say evaluate
some of my critique of grid in the book
is largely to hurt her colleagues credit
taken from their papers which just kind
of did not get into the public right
you're you're drawing different
conclusions from the same work yeah that
that book came from yeah and and based
on some of the stuff in their papers but
so the most famous study is of West
Point cadets US Military Academy cadets
going through it's called beast barracks
this rigorous six-week orientation and
grit was found to be a better predictor
the grit survey 12 questions survey half
the points are awarded for resilience
and half for consistency of interests
and grit turned out to be a better
predictor than whole candidate score
which is these more traditional measures
test scores athleticism all this stuff
and most cadets make it through beast
anyway and so that's good thing to know
that that crit is important for that but
there are a couple issues to keep in
mind one is you have what statisticians
call severe restriction of range so
basically these cadets were selected for
their whole candidate score and when you
do that when you select people for
something in that way
you basically exaggerate the effect of
other variables so it'd be like if I
study what causes basketball skill and
do my study with only centers in the NBA
and find well only practice got them to
the NBA not practice plus being seven
feet tall because I've selected a group
that's already pre-screened for height
so there's this restriction of range
issue which duckworth in her paper says
this this pre selection means that we
can't really extrapolate this to groups
outside of this study which is of course
exactly what has happened and not only
that but but like life is not a six-week
orientation right and so you've
pre-selected people for a very specific
short-term goal they're already in the
finals of the National Spelling Bee
they're already in West Point and so if
you open that time line a little bit and
look at those cadets down the line since
the 1990s about half of those very
gritty cadets who get through West Point
who get through Beiste and get through
West Point have
quitting the army almost on the day that
they are allowed and that's a more
modern phenomenon and so you know some
officials in the Army felt that this was
the army had develop when it developed a
great problem overnight like one
high-ranking official who'd suggested
defunding West Point because he was a
quote an institution that taught its
cadets to get out of the army which
obviously is not the case but what
turned out was actually the case is that
the army kept this upper out work
structure which worked in a more
industrialized world where where
organizations were highly specialized
and you faced repetitive challenges over
and over and over and so there are huge
barriers to lateral movement but as the
knowledge economy allowed lateral
movement and put a priority on people
with knowledge creation skills and
problem solve these broader skills and
you can have lateral movements and by
the way from age 18 to your late 20s is
the fastest time of personality change
in your life so the idea that people
these cadets were developing new
interest shouldn't be a surprise and so
they started leaving because they didn't
have control over trying to find a good
fit for themselves in the army so they
left and went outside and that's why the
army started these other programs to
give the highest potential officers more
autonomy over their career trajectory
because they realize they didn't develop
a grid problem overnight they developed
a match quality problem overnight and by
the way the day before this book came
out Angela Duckworth weekly newsletter
was called summaries for sampling you
know maybe this is a coincidence maybe
it isn't oh wow
but summers for sampling where she says
like this is when kids should sample a
bunch of stuff because of course you
shouldn't be too gritty until you figure
out what you should be doing and that's
what I did in my career for a decade
first and that's what everyone should do
so whether or not it's a coincidence
it's wonderful timing and I'm glad she
she shared that yeah and in the example
that you just gave it sort of dovetailed
also with the rise of the Information
Age and and you know more opportunities
you know abounding for these people that
made staying in the military less
attractive yeah because there were
greater opportunities outside of it
exactly so this so so even though we
perceive people as becoming more and
more specialized in work actually the
change to the knowledge economy opened
up this lateral mobility where there are
you know again when when we were in sort
of a kinder learning environment we were
facing the same challenges in the work
world wasn't changing as quickly
experience in a specific task was so
important that it was a huge barrier to
someone coming in from the side but now
that's not the case
and so obviously cadets on mass have
sort of realized their opportunities and
taken them yeah when I look at how that
kind of sports world intersects with the
business world and you know now these
are these worlds are the things that you
write about going back to this idea of
coaching and feedback you know this is
something that we get in sports it's
very direct in the work environment not
only do we have not have coaches that
are providing that kind of feedback
we're in environments where you're not
necessarily encouraged to succeed in
fact most you know people would prefer
that you not succeed so you're after a
meeting you're not told like hey do this
next time it'll be better they're like
well we're just gonna weed that guy out
and I'm gonna step on top of him and and
and move up the chain and so people are
living out their careers really not
connected to the results of their labor
in a way that's most favorable for their
upward mobility no I mean I think that's
a that's a absolutely apt observation
you know and again I think it's it's
also one of the points where I sort of
wanted to respond to some of sports as
an analogy for the work world because we
don't have to view the work world as
zero-sum in that way in the way they're
like you know a football game has to be
zero-sum like if someone's gonna win
someone else has to lose or if someone
else gets a certain number of catches
someone else is basically going to get
fewer and I think that's sort of a
problematic mindset in the work world
but but you're totally right right let's
talk about talent transfer a little bit
this is the idea that when you are a
generalist for a period of time that the
way that we learn certain things can
inform and apply to other skills so it's
really about learning how to learn as
much as it is about learning how to do a
specific thing yeah yeah yeah definitely
that ability to transfer and so to put
that and this is one area where we're
sports actually has been a more
appropriate analogy in some ways so some
countries like Australia and the UK when
they were gonna host the Olympics they
sort of looked at some of this science
that said oh actually maybe we should
let people
shuffle themselves around and search for
things and started these what they
called talent transfer programs which
essentially was in some ways kind of the
anti 10,000 hours school of thought not
in the sense that you don't need a lot
of deliberate practice to be good but in
the sense that here people who are older
you know they're old enough that if they
haven't made the national team we should
probably say you know you should go do
something else but just allowed them to
try other sports and both countries got
gold medalists out of those people who
had done a bunch of other sports hadn't
quite you know found their fit and but
they had learned these sort of broader
skills and actually the Australian
Institute of Sport when they were doing
that compiled this data that showed
people who had played at least three
invasion sports meaning like it's a real
time you know not taking turns but you
have to people are trying to get past
you or balls trying to get by you those
sorts of things will then more quickly
pick up subsequent sport skills going
forward so might be a little bit like
you know growing up bilingual where I
think a lot of the I was gonna write
more about multilingualism but I
couldn't convince myself that a lot of
the popular science is actually correct
but what did seem reasonable to me you
talk was work that showed that people
who grew up bilingual are better able to
learn a third language even if it's like
made up by the scientists in an
experiment without being told the rules
right and that's those are the skills
that you really need so put in another
context of maths are this one chapter
it's more about like the classroom kind
of learning there was just a study that
came out that I didn't have it came out
too recently for me to put it in range
or I certainly would have because it
gets to this issue called interleaving
that's one of the learning techniques I
talk about so in this study seventh
grade math classrooms were randomly
assigned two types of studying math some
got they would have problem do block to
practice problem type aaaa
bbbbb ccccc the other would get never
see the same problem twice always
different uh-huh and that that mixed
that interleaved that's called
interleaving when you mix it up that
group would be more frustrated you know
they rate their learning as less they'll
rate their teacher has worse and then
come test time when both groups have to
see problems they've never seen before
that group obliterates the other group
it was the effect size was on the order
of taking a kid from the 50th to the
80th person
right I'm being selective in what
percentiles I choose because if it was
higher when the move looking sounds
dramatic but because what they're
learning is not just how to execute
procedures for a certain type of problem
but how to match a type of thinking
strategy to the structure of a prob
right and that's the kind of
transferable knowledge that that you
learn if you're sort of a good
generalist yeah creative problem-solving
as opposed to just learning how to solve
a specific problem in a specific context
exactly and that's why one one
frustrating experience I had in
reporting range was when I was spending
some time with woman named Deidre
Kentner
who is probably the world's expert in
using analogies from like outside of our
domain to help you problem-solve
whatever you're facing and she came up
with this this study to make a long
story short where she was giving
Northwestern students these types of
problems and they had to essentially try
to solve them by identifying like the
deep structure of the problem and
students could do pretty well in their
specific major but most didn't do well
outside of their major even if the
structure of the problem was similar
just our features but the students who
did the best were these ones in this
program called the integrated science
program where they had no major they
just had all the they were supposed to
dabble in like all of the sciences and
they did the best on this but then when
I went around and asked other faculty
about that program you know why not
expand it they were like well cuz those
kids get behind because they don't have
a major I'm like here you have on your
faculty yeah the will probably the
world's expert in this type of
problem-solving saying here are the
students were equipping the best for
doing it and her own peers are saying
not good they're getting behind me I
don't like that's the cultural and
social pressure that's butting up
against this right there's so much
momentum behind the way that we've
always done it totally and I get it I
get it
so like whether you're a youth sports
coach so so for those faculty who are in
a specific department right like
departments are like a necessary evil of
making the way we study the world
comprehensible at some point you have to
put the world back together again but if
you're just in one department your
incentive is to have those customers
right you don't really care about the
others or if you're a when I was living
in Brooklyn up until not long ago there
was a you seven travel soccer team that
met nearby me like oh you seven yeah I
don't think anybody thinks that six
can't find good enough competition in a
city of nine million people right that
they have to travel
it's like those kids are customers for
someone all right and they need to keep
them from the other sports right and if
their incentive is only to win the six
year olds whatever it is then they're
just responding to their incentives
because their incentive isn't to develop
the best 20 or 30 or 40 year old right
soccer is a really interesting test case
example because it's such a massive
participation sport in the United States
and yet and on some level it's sort of a
generalist think it prepares you to to
play all different kinds of sports and
be an athlete in a multivariate way and
yet despite the massive numbers of young
people that participate in this sport we
don't seem to have the best system to
generate the best teams that can compete
at the highest level against you know
European and South American teams I mean
that's changing a little bit now but
what how do you make sense of that yeah
on the men's side on the women's side
women are crushing it but and the
women's side I mean I think is a
testament to opportunities right if you
go around the rest of the world like
American women have much better
opportunities in soccer in the rest of
the world and it's and that shows so
hopefully the American women won't crush
it as well at some point in the future
because other countries will have as
many opportunities for women to play but
I think and sometimes people say well in
frit on the men's side our best athletes
just are playing other sports and I
don't accept that explanation because if
you look at even the number of
registered players we have it's like way
more than the sayings that do way but
yeah yeah it's crazy but what we don't
really have but I think are starting to
sort of develop in other ways is like
the street soccer culture right if you
go to Brazil the kids are playing futsal
where they have the small ball stays on
the ground it's kind of heavier one day
they're playing on sand one day they're
playing on cobblestones different shaped
surface different number of people who
are playing on a basketball court
whatever so it's kind of a different
game all the time and I think because I
think the playing of multiple sports is
much more proxy just for your general
diversity of movement and
problem-solving I don't think it matters
that like you put on a basketball jersey
instead of a soccer jersey and so they
have that they grew up with that kind of
like more general kind of problem
solving and
that of this more formal soccer playing
at a lot of likely Americans have blown
up a practice right and even even so
after my first book when when I added
the afterword and wrote about
specialization I got a lot of feedback
that was like you know saying that
athletes who go on to become elite
usually have this like less structured
early beginning feedback from people
saying like maybe your dumb American
sports but not in not in football you
know not in soccer and right on cue this
was 2014 a study came out from Germany
looking at the development of their
amateur league players all the way up to
their national team who'd just won the
World Cup and showed that in fact the
members went on to the national team
played a lot less way less deliberate
much more unstructured activity when
they were kids dabbled in other sports
not until they were 22 did they start
can participate in more organized soccer
than these high-level amateur players in
France they started decades ago they
just won the World Cup they started
decades ago reforming their pipeline in
a way where the French kid who's in
their development pipeline probably
plays half as many organized games as an
American kid of the same age and they
very the challenge they played these
small sided games a different size pitch
and one of the guys who helped design
their system has a saying he said
there's no remote control and what he
meant is the coaches shouldn't try to
micromanage the players you want this
like organic problem solving in play and
so they restricted the time when the
coaches are even like allowed to talk
during those those smaller number of
games yeah well what I Intuit from that
is it's it's a loser it's it's a
cultural thing where it's just ingrained
into the way people are living on a day
to day basis it's not laden with the the
structure and the pressures that often
lead to burnout and making kids want to
do something else right like they allow
these young people to fall in love with
it and that becomes like deeply rooted
and I think that provides the foundation
for longer-term success yeah no I
totally agree and by the way our women
some of our best women you know Alex
Morgan and others did play variety of
sports and didn't specialize until later
but I completely agree so I think it's
it's our approach in the u.s. has been
with these like very specific
development programs where what you're
talking about and what I think is more
important is this sort of broader call
sure that the sport exists within and
that's how you really develop a large
number of these people who who can you
know become creative players at the top
level right a lot of what you talk about
is kind of an antidote to the tiger mom
philosophy and you even point out like
what was her daughter's name was like
Lulu Lulu was Mike like she quit by line
at 13 right nobody remembers like part
of the book though that's the whole
thing though yeah right like if she
quits at 13 then you've lost the game
yeah nobody remembers that sorry Sam on
page one of the book and so page one on
the book was the start of her the
excerpt of Battle Hymn of the tiger
mother in The Wall Street Journal and it
became the Wall Street Journal's most
commented on article ever you know both
very positive and very negative and on
page one she says here are the secrets
to raising serious typically successful
kids and she assigns one of her kids
violin you know and presides over like
five hours of practice a day or whatever
and then later in the book she says her
daughter says to her you picked it not
me and quit right and this is like in
study of 1200 musicians the most common
reason for quitting was the instrument
the kid wanted to play as different than
the one they are playing and and I gave
her credit for being reflective about
that she didn't have to put that in the
book but nobody remembers that part
that's interesting yeah I mean the the
individual has to take ownership of this
path and you know maybe the the parent
can perform some kind of inception to
make that happen but but but you know
short of that when it's the there's you
know the the tiger mom thing it's like
this is about the parent not about the
kid this is about the parent living
vicariously through their child to
succeed on a level that they couldn't or
whatever gets projected onto that child
and you know it's it's generally a
recipe for disaster yeah and I think
we've seen that now come out in these
incredibly perverse ways right with like
this college admissions right handles
that happened where you're sort of like
you know there's a level of okay I can
understand how parent might do this
because they don't want their kid to
fall behind even if they're not thinking
about you know what the kid might want
to do like getting them ahead in
something that the kid doesn't really
like but that that College Admission
scandal went to a a level where I'm
saying the only thing the only way I can
make sense of this is that like your
kids are jewel
that you're trying to show off because
this makes I can't even figure out
another context right ends a bet I think
it's also indicative of of you know what
I've heard described is like this this
snowplow parent snowplow culture where
you know parents feel like they just
have to clear this path for their kid in
order to succeed I don't think it's such
a good idea
you know it's it's it's it's running at
cross-purposes with you know the kind of
grit and the love of learning and the
exploration and the spirit that we want
to instill in our young people so like
how do you look at like what's going on
culturally with respect to parenting and
how do I like find a better way yeah I
mean I think again I think I think
systems are kind of set up in I think a
lot of our systems are sort of still
have like the residuals of like the
industrial era sort of because like our
education system has a lot of the
hallmarks of like Taylorism an
industrial management science where it's
like workers are gonna face repetitive
tasks they need to have a certain level
of certain types of skills and here's
how we're gonna turn them out just like
we do this stuff in industry it's
amazing given all the science how little
has changed in our educational systems
true it's true and so there's a part
there's a part in the book where I talk
about how everyone thinks like education
is getting worse right there like it was
better in my day and actually it's not
the case like if you look at like
there's no question that students today
have a better mastery of basic skills
then then like their parents did but if
you compare tests from a generation or
two ago to test now the kids have to
take it's like previously they could
just memorize formulas now they're asked
for these like much more difficult
problem-solving tactics so it's not that
school has gotten worse it's just that
the challenge has changed so rapidly to
prepare people for this more dynamic
work world and and I think we should
sort of embrace some experimentation
within that and realize that like we
should move a little bit of not that
there aren't basic skills that everyone
should learn but that maybe part of
developing young people should also be
facilitating some of that
experimentation and helping them find
the place where they fit instead of just
like kind of putting everyone through
that same conveyor belt so given
everything that you've learned and
studied if you were suddenly vested with
overhauling our educational system
you know maybe the high school level or
the junior high school level like what
would that look like like what would be
the systems that you would put into
place yeah I mean I think I would try to
do some of like what Dedra Gantner said
where I would sort of try to teach this
types of mental models for attacking
problems in different disciplines so it
would take different in the science and
the humanities in history and try to
kind of have those connected in a more
integrated system so that people
diversify their mental models but I
think I might be willing to experiment
with stuff like because I think so much
of what kids get in school is of so
little used to so many of them and not
not to say that again there aren't
certain things they should learn but
that I would almost be willing to like
come up with you know have a year or
something dedicated to experimenting and
like randomize them to learn a little
bit about different disciplines there
were these I cut something from range
but was looking at these studies of
what's called career academies where
kids who are probably not going to go to
college get into these programs where
they still have to learn the normal high
school stuff but they also are sort of
introduced to types of work in the world
where you know some vocational training
or internship or exposure and one of the
interesting things about the career
academies was those kids end up doing
better even if they go totally away from
the thing that they were getting that
education in and I think it suggests one
that they end up having these productive
interactions with an adult in their life
and also they get some signal about like
what work is like and what's possible
and if that's a thing they want to do or
not so I think I would facilitate much
more sort of of that kind of talent
based branching where it's like let's
expose you to some things and see like
what feels like a fit and yeah of
interestingness and and your you know
and your abilities I'm encouraged by
this kind of shift in perspectives about
careers that we're seeing with
Millennials and and and even the the
generation beneath them in the sense
that you know look the the idea that
you're gonna join this corporation and
be there for your lifetime has gone the
way of the dodo that doesn't exist
anymore and we're in this increasingly
more and more freelance based economy
where young people are interested less
in security and more in experience and
are more likely to kind of gravitate and
move around and try all different kinds
of things and work
and travel and do this and and to me
reading your book and understanding
where you're coming from that seems to
be an encouraging signal of people that
are going to be more you know have all
of these general experiences that are
going to inform more well-rounded people
who will be better at these kinds of
problem-solving skills
yeah I think also it allows you to make
your career and the stuff you do more
reflective of who you are right because
even most very specialized people like
they're doing that because it's an
advantage it's not like necessarily
they're like self-actualization but also
I think like if you believe in any kind
of market principles this is a market
for human capital and the less friction
we have the people trying these
different things and cobbling together
these different roles I think the more
productive you make those people so it's
like the phrase I'd like to keep in my
head is when you get fit it looks like
grit right grit I think there's you know
some evidence that grit is a state not a
trait meaning that it's not just an
innate characteristic right like I was a
college runner some of the people who
were the grittiest people I've ever seen
on the track were the biggest chickens
I've ever seen in the classroom and vice
versa and it has a lot to do with your
context and then when you get someone in
the right fit their behavior will look
like grit right so if we can let people
do a little bit of that triangulating I
think we end up with more productive
people yeah there's a weird thing where
it seems like on paper that a
high-performing athlete who understands
the importance of you know diligence and
focus and grit and perseverance and and
knows how to work hard and you know
achieve a goal that that would translate
seamlessly into the workforce and that
was not my experience trying to make
that transition from athlete to
professional and more often than not
with high-performing athletes that I
know they they experience this period of
confusion and loss and they just can't
translate this amazing skill set that
they have into the workplace and you
have some cool interesting thoughts
about that but let's explore that for a
moment ya know I think and you know I
know a lot of retired pro athletes and
that is absolutely the norm with very
few exceptions like maybe some guys go
into you know like support
rod casting right away but those that
don't I think right when you're just a
civilian overnight right right that
there's this like incredible period of
of identity change that needs to happen
and they do have skills that they can
use right there are things that they can
take that they can use but they there
are also things like that they haven't
developed and an identity that sort of
they haven't fleshed out in those ways
and so I think it can be like really
traumatic you know there's a form of
that that sort of partly prompted me to
write the book not with athletes but
with these people who had been given
scholarships by the Pat Tillman
foundation these were former military or
some current military and military
spouses who were given these
scholarships to aid career changes
essentially and one of my college
training partners was a Tillman Scholar
he was giving away scholarships I got
invited to speak to a tiny group of them
it was like 15 or 20 people and because
my that my buddy thought that like this
sort of talking about late
specialization in sports would resonate
with them because their career changing
and I sort of said well I better like
also put some non sports stuff in it you
know because they're not athletes and
that's sort of what led to the first
research and looking in other domains
and I sort of tacked that on to the end
of the talk
and they like every one of them like
came up to me after and and you know
we're saying like this is so good to
hear a guy an ex-navy seal who was in
grad school at Dartmouth and Harvard at
the same time sent me this note saying
later saying where we were so relieved
to hear this like they all feel so
behind and not only in their profession
but also in this identity shift and they
have these incredible experiences and
these incredible you know leadership and
problem solving and and determination
skills but they've been made to feel so
far behind right and so it was odd to me
almost that it was like catharsis for
them to hear that like you know these
are good things that you've done like
these will help you it's just but it's
gonna take a period of transition
because your identity doesn't change
overnight
interesting where does talent come into
play here I mean this is something that
you talked about in sports gene yeah
like how do you how do you square talent
with all these other ideas that you're
juggling yeah and I mean I obviously
having written my first book think that
you know talent is an important thing
and and I should say the proposal for my
first book did not think that like I
thought it was gonna be a 10,000 hours
book and I was you know after I spent a
year like looking in that literature can
convinced otherwise but that that both
talent and and environment are both very
important but I think there are you know
certain studies like outside of the
sports world that I've followed over
time where you can see that when people
have like ability tilts where they're
sort of better at certain things than
others they can start to triangulate
that over time and they become more
satisfied and more productive when they
get in a place that like them it tends
to match their abilities that's not to
say everyone has to like things that
they're good at by any stretch of the
imagination but obviously a lot of other
things come with that positive feedback
and these sorts of things and so I think
we underestimate how important it is to
try to find like where our talents might
most fit all right part of those talents
just being being voraciously interested
in something and then you're gonna work
really hard at it and if you don't
believe in talent at all then you should
do the 10,000 hours right because just
pick something and like go crazy at it
right you like we could randomly assign
people right what they're doing but I
don't think we can randomly assign
people to what they're doing because of
our different talents and interests and
so I think it's incredibly important to
find that place where you where you fit
where you will display the
characteristics of grit but some people
are just voraciously hard or hardwired
to be voraciously interesting interested
in things and some people are not like
is this a teachable thing like I guess
if you have an amazing teacher that can
like light a spark in you yeah one thing
but there are certain people that just
are expansive in their curiosity and
others aren't ya know I mean some people
just become polymaths right like in in
in one chapter of range actually right
about these studies of inventors where
like there you can classify inventors by
some of them are if you look at their
patent history they're 450 different
patent classes and of Technology and you
can see some have drilled into like one
or two areas some have spread their work
across a huge number of areas so there's
specialists in general and they both
make important contributions then there
are people who have done like not that
many
different classes and haven't gone that
deep in one and they don't make very big
contributions so they're like not all
that interested anything and then
they're the polymaths who either start
in an area with some depth and then
become really broad or start broad and
zero in on an area of depth and those
are the people that make like the
biggest contributions right these who
are sort of Polymathic and I don't think
that's you know I think they're
following their interests and they just
have these sort of daily voracious
interests yeah their their talent is
their curiosity right totally totally
and and I think that and again looking
at that patent research the the impact
of these broader people has been
exacerbated since about the mid 80s
again in the sort of as communication
technology is allowed information to be
disseminated more quickly and more
thoroughly they can combine they can
gather up things from all these
different domains and and make
combinations of knowledge you know so
sometimes their patents will like have a
dozen classes listed in like one thing
that they're doing and so I think this
is a particularly good area era for
really curious people because so much
information is available and you can
combine things in way that the people
who are more narrow can't do but if
you're not that curious someone actually
asked me recently an event was saying
how do I broaden my mental models you
know and get this kind of thinking and
problem solving if I'm not like really
that innately curious of a person and
that's a really hard question you know
but you can assign tasks you can say
read books ya know I mean eventually
you'll come across something that
hopefully would light a spark in that
person totally and also and it's all
matter of degree right like I'm gonna
continue kind of triangulating my
interest in my whole life I don't think
I'm gonna like get to a place where I'm
finished you know I keep doing this and
there are things involved in work that I
love that parts that I don't love that
I'm doing because I'm like this is a
habit I need to get this worth done
mm-hmm and so maybe if not being as
curious is something that doesn't come
as easily for some people you have a lot
of options now audiobooks you know
podcasts like you can do things that
have a lower barrier of effort than they
would have in the past
and I think you know take advantage of
that if that's if that's one of your
weaknesses or things like you know Shane
Parrish I don't know if you ever
realized he's doing this we sort of
realized we connected because we
realized we're basically that kind of
writing about the same thing yeah yeah
yeah anyways and so you know so I was
giving some feedback on the next volume
of
great mental models project and I think
sort of part of what that project is is
him saying look if you're not gonna be
sort of as interested in the stuff the
way I was I'm gonna kind of package it
for you so that you can do it without as
much work and so I think those things
are available yeah well I mean look I'm
an old guy yeah I I came up in a
different era where you go to college
and you take you know certain courses
and you major in something and then you
go to the Career Center and you look at
these brochures for consulting companies
and investment banks and you think well
this is this is it you know and now with
the internet you could listen to you
know countless hours of podcasts and
audiobooks and just you know on on the
kind of theme that you explore of like
exposing yourself to a lot of different
things there's never been a better time
to be able to do that and to do it for
essentially for free that's right this
whole universe of knowledge is available
to everybody that has a smartphone yeah
and again not not to like keep harping
on her minibar --is work but it
resonated with me and my own career path
you know very much where you know we
don't need to have this idea that like
you hit on something it's like lightning
necessarily that that may happen but all
this stuff when she was looking at these
people who made successful career
transitions and found much more
fulfilling work usually the spark came
from they met someone at a dinner party
or they read about something they didn't
know about it was it was or the fringe
of their network they connected with
somebody wasn't like their inner circle
because they knew about that stuff it
was like chance exposure to something
well there's the Girl Scouts woman is a
great example of that yeah yeah and she
I just saw her the other day as Frances
Hesselbein who's just like a hundred or
102 now she's a hundred and three and a
half hundred and three well and I'm
still teaching at West Point and running
an organization in Manhattan so she was
she became a little bit of like a role
model for me actually where she she had
to drop out of junior college she's born
in 1915 in Johnstown Pennsylvania and
now to drop out a junior college because
her father was passing away and she had
to take care of the family got a job as
like an assistant to an advertising
executive those the only job she ever
applied for and after that she sort of
did odd jobs like helping her husband
with photography studio and all these
sorts of things she called her dad
helping
whatever was needed she would do it and
in her 30s a woman in her community came
and asked her like will you volunteer to
lead a Girl Scout troop
because the other leader left and she
says no I don't know no no experience
not a leader I only have a little boy
don't know anything about girls and the
woman finally tells her like well we're
gonna have to disband these group of
girls from modest families who meet in a
church basement if you don't do it
because everyone else has declined she's
just fine I'll do six weeks and then
find out find a real leader and during
that time she sort of starts reading
about the Girl Scouts realize they're
founded eight years before women could
vote you know and and that the leader
told girls you can be a lawyer a doctor
an aviatrix
or a hot-air ballooning aviatrix yeah
and Francis realized he remembered being
in second grade and saying she want to
be a pilot and people laughing at her so
she ends up sticking with that troop til
they graduate high school and basically
she keeps picking up jobs in Girl Scouts
where people where she keeps saying like
I'll do this for a month or two you know
and she keeps realizing every time she
does it that she likes it or she's
making a big impact they asked her to
chair United Way campaign when a woman
had never done that before still only
two women have done that and the most
recent one was like a year ago or
something and so she does that and it's
like Johnstown has the highest
per-capita giving in the country that
year and finally they wanted to be an
executive director of a local Girl
Scouts Council which is actually a
professional job everything else has
been volunteering this is in her mid-50s
she said no no I'm a volunteer like I've
never had a professional job and again
they say well you know then this there's
gonna be like the finances are all
messed up there's gonna be like problems
if you don't do it so should find six
months you know I'll do it six months
then get the book straightened out get a
real leader and she gets totally
addicted to it again right and one thing
leads to another finally they were
interviewing her to be the CEO of the
Girl Scouts they're having this huge
crisis where in the 60s like society's
changing and Girl Scouts is like girls
need information about sex and drugs and
careers in math and science and Girl
Scouts is stuck in like kind of home a
commode you know and she says no no no I
went on living in Pennsylvania my whole
life I'm not going and the previous CEOs
had been like you know the woman who
founded the u.s. women's Coast Guard
Reserve and was a university dean
Francis was one of 355 local Girl Scout
council leaders so she goes to New York
doesn't want to take the job but her
husband says you have to turn
down in person and so he drives her to
New York and she she's not nervous
because she's not gonna take it she
describes total transformation of of the
operation get rid of the old handbook
get a bunch of new ones that appeal of
different ages to two girls of different
backgrounds and you know get rid of the
current management structure all this
stuff and they invite her back as the
CEO so this professional journey she
started in her mid-50s she becomes the
CEO basically saves the organization
increases gets a hundred and thirty
thousand new volunteers right people
she's paying in sense of mission not in
money it explodes the minority
participation right she commissions all
this messaging specifically for minority
girls like what she tells one of her the
artist is if if an indigenous girl and
an ice floe in Alaska reopens this book
she better see herself in a Girl Scout
uniform and she's being told while doing
this like
don't like focus on the finance problems
first and then diversity like I mean she
says no diversity is the problem and so
she goes all in on that and just like
saves the organization the cookie
business becomes a third of a billion
dollars a year and every stop in her
life like when I went to interview her
and I say like you know what trains you
for leadership she waves me off and goes
like don't ask me that question I never
knew I was being trained I was doing
what was needed at the time and that I
used her stories this example entity you
know even after she thought she retired
she didn't and now she's doing something
else and working five days a week at 103
and a half and I used it as an example
of this research that suggests that the
people who find the most fulfilling
careers have that orientation towards
short-term planning where instead of
saying here's I'm gonna be in 10 or 20
years like the commencement speech kind
of thing they say here's why I'm right
now here my interest in the you know
skills and things I want to learn for
Francis it was like what's an
opportunity to serve and I'm gonna try
this maybe you're from now I'll change
cuz I will have learned something about
myself and she just did that all the way
through her whole career and is still
doing that yeah I mean what I took from
that is is is just her servant service
mindedness like that was what what it
was about for her and then she just
she's getting dragged into all these
opportunity like she's kicking and
screaming to not do it and they keep
saying no you need to do this and so
she's reacting
to her environment yeah her upward
mobility is you know her resisting it
almost yeah alway yeah she becomes you
know Peter Drucker this famed management
expert calls her the best CEO in America
unlike and at the end of this and so
she's become she won the National Medal
of Freedom which is the highest civilian
award that you can win but it was always
like that she would sort of get pushed
into it she would see an opportunity to
serve because that was important to her
and then would sort of get sucked in and
realized like it really fit her but
another of the lessons from me from that
was like you can't just figure this out
a priori I wish you could you actually
have to try stuff sometimes to figure
out like what works for you
right I mean when you look it look you
know retro actively back on the history
of your trajectory in your career is
this the result of some scheme that you
white boarded and said this is what I
want to be doing I I'm just like I know
for myself like I would have I don't you
know like I don't know how I got here I
don't know you know I'm just sort of
gravitating towards my interest now in a
way that I didn't know how to do as a
younger person and I'm curious you know
as somebody who's looked at a number of
successful people across a number of
disciplines how many of those people are
in a similar situation where you know
like that like the Girl Scouts woman
just you know found themselves in a
place they never would have thought
because they didn't have you know
there's this pressure like you got to
have what's your five-year plan what's
your 10-year plan it's all scripted and
you're on this path versus you know
looking at the people that are super
successful and saying no it's more like
this it's messy its unpredictable
you know someone were to say how do I
get where you know to where you're
you're at their answer is I have no idea
right that's that's so interesting you
know and that I love that like the
10-year plan the investor Paul Graham
says in computer science we call that
premature optimization because like
you're setting the goal before you sort
of know who you are but to that point
like I can fit together all my pieces in
retrospect but I couldn't yeah look
backwards it like oh of course it all
lined alright hey making the stars but
so when I was at Sports Illustrated and
you'd get you know asked a lot by
younger aspiring
sports writers like if I want to work at
Sports Illustrated ESPN or whatever
should i major in journalism or English
and my first instinct was to say
journalism right and my second instinct
was to say English and my third instinct
was say I studied geology in astronomy I
have no idea right but even my instinct
was to say like well obviously you
should get a lead if you can yeah right
but and that's so that feels like the
right thing to do but but your to your
question of how many of the people sort
of do the Frances Hesselbein I mean I
use her as the lead-in to this research
called the Dark Horse project which is
about how people find fulfilling work
and it didn't start with the name the
Dark Horse project the way it got that
was these two researchers at Harvard
were studying people who find
fulfillment a lot of them were also you
know materially successful but that
wasn't but not all that wasn't
necessarily requirement and they would
all come in and say like well don't tell
people to do what I did cuz I started on
this other path you know I thought was
gonna be a doctor or lawyer or whatever
right and then I sort of zig zag and I
like stopped a couple things and then I
ended up with this like weird
opportunity and so you know you
shouldn't tell people to be like me and
most of them describe themselves that
way that's why they credit the Dark
Horse project they all viewed themselves
as having come out of know everyone's a
dark horse right right yeah yeah the
vast majority there was some like who
were then here but a very small number
yeah it wasn't much smaller and so how
do you square that with this
conventional wisdom that you know you
can't score if you don't have a goal
like you know we're all set it like
everyone's everyone's this Dark Horse
and yet they're telling everyone else to
adhere to this paradigm yeah that
actually isn't how they got there yeah
yeah no and I think it's and some of the
Dark Horse's did set you know medium or
longer-term goals but it was like after
this period of experimentation basically
so it's not to say you can never set
goals but they were much more oriented
toward moving forward from like the
opportunities right in front of them and
and that's that's for me Ben for sure
the way my most important projects have
come from these you know some
conversation I didn't expect or some
interaction that I didn't really expect
so now when people ask you you know what
should I do to be a journalist yeah now
now I you got to be honest now yeah no I
mean I sort of try to tell them what my
background was and I think there are
many different ways to to get to good
outcomes right there's many different
possible paths as there are people but
my suggestion would
actually be to study something other
than journalism right right find these
other interests like you'll be able to
do the journalism and you're gonna need
stuff to write about and you'll learn a
lot of the sort of boots-on-the-ground
stuff like just through the practice and
so I would encourage them to like have a
little bit of that sampling period in
college and study something else like
that one of the match quality studies I
loved was this economist who wanted to
see he used the English and Scottish
school systems as a comparison where
they're very similar except for the
English students have to specialize
earlier and what he found was that those
students where the Scottish students can
special I can sample a little longer and
we found the English students jump out
to an income lead after college because
they have more domain-specific skills
but then the scouter students pick
better fits because they get to sample
and so they have faster growth rates so
they quickly erase that income gap and
then the English students start quitting
their career tracks and much higher
numbers even though they have huge
disincentive from doing so because
they've sunk more time in it and so I
would kind of share stuff like that I
think like share some of the evidence
with people and say the one or two years
you're gonna put into experimenting can
pay big dividends and you're gonna be in
journalism for a long time like having
another model of how to think about
things is really really useful right
that that can really set you apart well
also if you want to be a writer you have
to live life yeah even if you're
reporting on other things the best
writers are the people who have rich
life experiences from which to draw upon
totally Tom Lake a writer who I really
like said CNN now was that at Sports
Illustrated I remember him once asking
me how I got onto a certain story I
wrote this story about Lance Mackey who
won the Iditarod four times in a row and
he had won he had done this like several
times in a row had won like the two
longest races both the Iditarod and
another like a thousand mile race and I
wrote this story about him and it was
great I loved it you know as some of it
ended up in the sports gene and it was
just this wonderful experience and he
was sort of like how in the world did
you end up with this guy and I was like
well after the Vancouver Olympics you
know when you work really hard nobody
keeps track of you @si for a couple
weeks after the Olympics and so I was
like so when dogsledding you know and
like met someone in dog sledding and
kind of start asking questions and they
start telling me about this guy Lance
Mackey and whatever and so I go up and
he's like fine you can interview me as
long as I
you work in my dog yard while like we're
interviewing so this was the hardest
transcription I've ever had was barking
and all this stuff in the but I remember
Tom saying sort of like this a good
reminder that the way to find
interesting stories is to live an
interesting life yeah there's no
question about that when when you were
describing the differences between the
the Scottish in the English educational
system I was curious if in the course of
doing all this research you came across
one country whose really figured out the
model that that you think is going in
the right direction like is there any
country in terms of our educational
system that is you know doing things
that are in line with these ideas that
you're exploring that's a good question
I mean I think I think Finland is a good
one
but I also am always hesitant to draw
too strong of comparisons between
Finland and the US because there has
been a lot of like we should do what
Finland does but we have a lot of social
complexities that they don't have and so
I think it makes them easier to sort of
implement some of these kinds of things
like they're very oriented toward like
nature education earlier in education
toward like multilingualism and towards
insects sort of much more holistic and
you know they end up doing like
phenomenally well on international tests
and all those things but again they have
some they it's a very small country you
know that's very financially well-off
and they don't have some of the
challenges that we have on the sports
front I think Norway there was just a
great HBO real sports looking at Norway
how they've basically like banned formal
competition below the age of 12 and they
heard about that exploded the Winter
Olympics you like best performance ever
I think in in limited cases there's like
the way Japan teaches math where they do
instead of this using procedures
knowledge they if you go in they'll be
like a blackboard that takes the whole
wall of a room and they'll work on one
problem the entire class and the kids
have magnets with their name on it and
they're asked like what's an approach to
this problem and they come up to the
board
they put an approach on and the problems
will incorporate like several different
types of concepts that can be brought to
bear and though their suggestion may be
wrong but they get to put their name
magnet on it and you follow it and you
sort of take that on one course then
another kids suggest something else and
you follow all their different courses
and
the end of the class you have this one
problem that's covered a whole
blackboard and all your sort of false
starts of attempting to solve it there's
a word for this called bond show which
is this a word for that type of
blackboard writing in Japan that like
tracks the intellectual journey of the
class and they really impart that sort
of that making connections knowledge
where you have to connect concepts to
try to solve a problem to such a degree
that one of the researchers I talked to
said we have trouble labeling like the
types of lessons when we did a videotape
to Havanese classrooms because there's
so many concepts in each problem that we
it's hard for us to say it's they're
teaching this concept right now and so I
think you know there there are aspects
of different countries the way to
operate like that for Japan that there
yeah well they're they're learning how
to problem-solve in a very dynamic way
yeah that then is applicable across
multi you know a multitude of
disciplines and they're learning how to
you know approach something complex and
figure out their own process for solving
it as opposed to like alright you carry
the one and like you you learn the
system for solving a math problem but
you don't really understand what's
actually behind it to a to an incredible
degree so like when I was reading some
of these studies about the math
knowledge that college students have
like sometimes you could be fooled into
thinking they knew a lot because they
could execute certain procedures but
then if you changed a problem just a
little it was clear they hadn't no idea
what's going on right and sometimes you
know to use like like a very distressing
sort of lower math level example there
was like one of these college students
who was being studied was you know given
like in whatever I don't know is like
500 plus 200 equals 700 or something I
say well how can you check if this
answer is right and I said okay well 700
minus 200 equals 500 right what's
another way you could check if this
answer is right and they couldn't come
up with 700 minus 500 equals 200 because
they'd been told you subtract the one to
the right of the plus sign right from
the one that's on the other side of the
equal sign and you're like holy cow like
you can so someone could get by doing
that right till you really like you
capacities understanding but you don't
actually understand because our entire
educational system is set up on breath
not depth yeah yeah well it's set up on
I would say on this using procedures
knowledge unlearning this using
procedures knowledge which is is too
be sort of the opposite of the kind of
breath you need where you need these
like broader conceptual models right I
see what you're saying yeah yeah yeah
what about the idea that when we're very
young were able to learn things you know
in a very facile way like you know you
teach a very young child how to you know
a different language they didn't pick it
up very quickly you know my own personal
case swimming like if you learn how to
swim well yeah when you're six years old
you'll have that for life you try to
teach like a 30 year old how to swim it
doesn't know how to swim it's like
they're never gonna they're just net
they're never gonna get to that same
place so what is it about that early
period in childhood development that
applies to kind of these ideas that
you're working with yeah I think you
have an enormous you know I think we
used to think that you sort of built up
these neuronal connections like as you
did stuff when you're a kid and now the
model is more like you have all these
all these neurons and you sort of prune
things away and strengthen the ones that
you're actually going to use so sort of
you like trade a measure of cognitive
flexibility for more efficiency and the
things they're actually going to do and
you know I think those are important
periods to take advantage of in to know
like what are the things that you should
expose people to and then time like
languish we do it totally backward right
like we like well they're too late yeah
and and again I think there's evidence
that if someone's bilingual in that fade
like before the age of 12 basically they
have an advantage for picking up later
language or if they've played multiple
invasion sports before about that same
age then they'll have an advantage for
picking up more so I think the most
important question would be what things
are like that where if we if we sort of
give them a broad base it will
facilitate this later learning later on
and I think you know a lot of sports are
like that languages like that and I
think maybe a lot of other things are
like that too so you know if someone
does find something that they truly like
love and it lights them on fire like
that's totally great but I do think that
that some of that broader base early on
can scaffold
this sort of more later specific
learning mm-hmm there's a sense of
relief with with this book in the sense
that I think there are a lot of people
yeah there are there's there's certain
people who find that thing that they're
great at and that they absolutely love
when they're very young and they can
then do that their entire life like you
know they picked up the guitar when
they're five and you know they have a
whole career into their 90's you know
doing that one thing but those are the
rare exceptions and I feel like there's
so many people who who just like feel
bad about themselves because they
haven't found that thing and what's
great about the book is that it's like
you can exhale like you don't have to be
that person you can try all these
different things and it's a it's a
pressure valve release to encourage
people to explore and not feel like they
have to you know fall into this specific
niche or they're falling behind yeah and
I mean it's it's a little bit of a
relief for me in that way too because I
really don't know what I'm going to do
next and I really have gotten like
whatever I asked you that right yeah
yeah and but I'm less embarrassed about
saying that then I was in the past
partly because I can at least say like
well I'm you know living by my tenets
that I was writing about here but I do I
am much more so where I used to have
like after I got done with running I
used to keep pretty assiduously a
training Journal and would have pretty
specific goals and these sorts of things
and I started doing that in my personal
life after I got out of running and
realized that actually like wasn't super
helpful for me it was you know either I
got to that goal or I didn't and it
wasn't actually helping me move there in
a way and so now instead I have what I
call a book of experiments where I use
it the way I did when I was a science
grad students here's something I'd like
to learn about myself am i interested in
this you know do I think I could be good
at it whatever do I have access to
training in it
and I'll try something and then you know
be sort of a scientist of myself and and
write the conclusions and and that's
really I'm just doing that to prompt
reflection in myself
and I've found that to be much more
useful to me than the kind of training
journal that I did find useful when I
was a runner right it's hard though like
I don't want to you know show up at a
jiu-jitsu class and you know be the
worst part you know I
I don't want to put myself in those
situations and generally I don't you
know like I want to do more of the
things that I'm good at yeah I want to
train the discipline that you know makes
me feel encouraged but when I have the
you know gumption to do that it's all it
always ends up being good thing that's
interesting I mean you have found things
I would say like you've done a much
better job than most people at finding
things that really do interest you and
sort of continuing to like mold your
life around your interest in some ways
yes in some ways no though you know I
think I still stick to like okay I'm
good at this I'm gonna stay here yeah
but most I mean you're a lawyer right
like most of them are still probably
most your colleagues are probably still
lawyer that's true right so it's we're
not talking about a real high bar for
people like sort of molding their their
life around them unfortunately but I
think we do we get in these like ruts of
competence right I was talking The
Economist Russ Roberts he sits a hammock
of competence because it's so
comfortable that you don't want to get
it out and I think it's like an
illustrative example this will sound
really weird but I was at certain point
like reading all the speed typing
literature okay like how do you get
faster typing and it turns out that most
of us will get up to you know 50 to 80
words a minute and then we'll settle
there naturally but actually you can get
much faster but it requires you to
basically take a metronome take it up a
little bit and follow that speed no
matter how many mistakes you make uh-huh
and then you just keep doing that little
by little and you can like double your
speed but it suggests to me that we sort
of will naturally will with experience
will get better but then we'll like some
for some reason naturally plateau at a
level of like very good and it's like
you know if you go to the weight room
and lift the same number of weights at
the same times every day you won't slide
backward but you might not get better
and so I think even within your thing
it's important to do things that make
you like a little bit yeah well it
becomes like this asymptotic curve like
it you know at some point the amount of
work that you have to put in to get
incrementally better just becomes
unjustifiable yeah right yeah yeah and
but then you can do these sorts of
things like this skill stacking right
which is where you don't have to be once
you get to that you're starting to
approach that asymptote you don't have
to you know if you're running like the
100 meters like then you know you that's
like total zero-sum competition you know
0.5% difference between competitors is a
blowout
but in most of the world we can take
sort of a little of what we're good at a
little bit here and if you stack them in
a unique way you're kind of competing on
turf that no one's competing with you
with right and that's I think sort of
something that's been useful for for
both of us this might sound like a
little woowoo but what I found as I get
older it seems like time accelerates
like you know it's like what it was just
coupe wait it's Christmas again you know
like it things just things things happen
really increase with increasing rapidity
and my experience of time but when I
take an opportunity to do something that
I have no experience in and I get
outside my comfort zone and invest
myself and some new activity time slows
down like I don't know if you've had
that experience in your own life and I
don't know why that is neurologically
but I find it to be true no I've totally
had that experience and I can only guess
at the reasoning which is like you know
when when certain things are kind of
more automated and they kind of move
from these like your prefrontal cortex
to these these more sort of automated
parts of your brain you are doing that
sort of unconsciously in a way right and
I wonder if that that sort of dulls are
in the moment nests in a way where like
you're it's just it's just happening
something a base presence right for your
own right variance right and so it might
be comforting and you feel competent but
I do think there's something kind of
lost there like when I think back on
there some like short parts of my life
like when I lived in the Arctic I lived
on a ship for awhile like those parts
weren't that long but they were so
different that they feel like such long
and important and impactful memories to
me yeah because they were so
uncomfortable and so unusual and so you
know it's everyone's choice but for me
that's kind of the life you don't want
to live I mean with the journalist
aspect of what you do it allows you to
tap into all these different worlds and
you know become part of subcultures that
you wouldn't ordinarily experience and I
would imagine that that you know that
aspect of what you do would keep you you
know fresh and engaged I mean and it
also brought out things in me that I
didn't know where like when I talk about
these if-then personality signatures in
range where I was like a shy
person naturally but in my journalistic
role I'm not shy and so it doing it kind
of got me and you know brought out some
some personalities are called free
traits when you can sort of take on a
personality trait that you don't sort of
have in the rest of your life and so I
enjoyed finding out that about myself
because then I felt like oh I can
probably do this and other things but
very much to your point like when I was
science you know aiming to be a
scientist my work was getting so narrow
that I really started asking myself
pretty quick and I the type of person
who wants to spend my whole life
learning one thing new to the world and
we need those people for sure or the
type of person who wants to spend much
shorter spans of time learning things
that are new to me and connecting them
and translating them and I was
definitely the latter and that's kind of
the lifeblood of the work I've gotten
into you know interesting
well there's sort of a fundamental
premise in the book it's a call to
action to embrace being a generalist but
implicit in that is that at some point
you're gonna specialize it's something
like if you want to be really excellent
like there is the rare polymath but
dabble in all these things until you
find that thing and then find your lane
and and specialize in that so you're you
know it's sort of like a wide generalist
triumph in a specialized world
ultimately you're still saying like at
some point you're gonna have to
specialize I mean I think it's very much
you know a semantic issue at some level
and like I have to admit that right it's
like what even is a generalist or a
specialist right I can tell you in the
patent research it's based on how many
different technological classifications
someone worked and in comic book
research it's it has to do with how many
genres someone is well yeah but but each
of those areas of science that I cite
like defines it in a specialized way for
that area and so in the wider world it's
like a semantic issue and like how
specialized or not am I like I to a
scientist I've income you know from
science into writing I look very non
specialized to other journalists I might
look quite specialized because I'm
always doing the science stuff so I
think it's sort of context dependent
mm-hmm
and so my real hope is to you know I
think we need both specialists and
generalists in every field I like how
Freeman Dyson styled it the physicist he
said we need frogs and birds the frogs
are down in the mud looking at the
details the birds are up above
integrating a knowledge of
frogs yeah he said the problem is we're
telling everybody to be frogs and that's
not good for a healthy ecosystem and so
I think you know this this discussion of
how broad or specialized to be that is
important I think either implicitly or
explicitly to everyone and my hope is to
make that conversation more interesting
and productive and I think that's like
the best thing I can hope for yeah and I
think it depends upon how you define or
think about what specialization is and I
think in this freelance economy where
people are empowered to cultivate and
craft careers that never existed before
yeah you can be the specialist of of you
yeah in certain respects like who else
has the life experiences that you it's
like there's no one else who could write
this book other than you so you are as
you are specialists in being writing
rage right now the semantics are gonna
come right well like in my case it's
like alright I was a lawyer I was an
athlete I've done these certain things
and so when I host a podcast I'm able to
bring a perspective that you know
someone else you know couldn't because
they've lived a different life and it
reminds me of you know sam harris has
his waking up and and kind of he makes
these preparatory remarks about why he
created this app and he's like you know
I'm a neurologist I spent all this time
doing meditation and you know I have
experiences with like these six things
none of which I'm the best at there's
people there are better meditators there
are better neuroscientists all this but
who there's no one else who has some
level of expertise in these five or six
things which makes me really the only
person who could you know create this
app that speaks to these this variety of
issues yeah totally that's that kind of
said he's so he's specializing in being
sam harris yeah yeah he like not in
being a neurologist who also has a
meditation app and a podcast and writes
best-selling books yeah yeah I mean yeah
and that's kind of skill stacking right
he says he's not the best anymore thing
but he sort of creates this ground that
only he's competing on if he exactly
knows things there is no competition
really ya know and that's like I said
that's the way like I didn't want to be
at Sports Illustrated running 100 meters
you know with all because there's it's
because there's like 50
line to be you know for that sort of in
that kind of zero something and so I
think you know you want to get on your
own ground and sometimes it's
interesting to hear you make the point
that like that's a sort of
generalization that becomes its own
specialization in a way right cuz like
one of my favorite interviews was with
this guy Oliver Smithies this Nobel
laureate who was studying to be a doctor
and then he saw a chemistry lecture and
was like that seems awesome like I'm
gonna go take that and then all of a
sudden as he put it now I'm not afraid
of biology and I'm not afraid of
chemistry and he sort of pioneers
biochemistry which now is viewed as its
own specialization right and
subspecialties but at the time was like
wool like Bud hybrid very broad you know
so sometimes those sorts of things this
that generalization can just become its
own right like it's back to that idea of
cell division right increasing
specialization as we kind of progressed
as a culture and a society yeah so when
you extrapolate from all of these ideas
we talked about education but let's talk
about you know the professional
environments like the workforce like how
would you reimagine how we structure
traditional work environments that can
create more fertile environments to
encourage generalizations so that you
can create a workforce that actually is
happy doing what they're doing and
they're finding you know they're finding
that place where they can actually excel
and be fulfilled yeah I think I think
some of it again is to to try to
incorporate some of and I say this only
because it's like we've been working for
the army where they had this incredibly
and and there's always going to be some
barriers to lateral moving in the army
like you can't get rid of that because I
like ranks and all these things but if
an institution that hierarchical can
adjust in a way that allows people to
sample such that it improves retention
even in what's like in many ways the
most hierarchical organization we can
have in society then I think other
workplaces should take a cue from that
and say well we have a lot more liberty
to allow people to sample into you know
maybe provide some of that coaching and
reflection when they're trying things
you know and and not just give lip
service to them failing right because
I've been a lot of these conferences and
everyone's like failure is great and
then but then when I talk to people
about when they actually failed like
nobody's like great like that way that
was a problem worth taking
in rare cases there are some like the 3m
inventors they said they would get that
was a problem worth investigating even
though it failed but that's rare usually
you know so I think we have to have more
than just lip service to to failure and
build that in and allow people to do
some of that zigzagging inside and to
give a specific example a podcast that I
love that I was on recently was the Bill
Simmons podcast he's very popular I
listen to us and and when I was there
like he was you know ESPN's most popular
writer and then he went to HBO and that
basically failed there and then he
started the wringer and that was like
when I was around there I was only there
for a little bit just seemed to me like
one of the happiest workplaces and what
as bill took me around introduced me
some people and I already knew some
people there from sports media what
occurred to me was it was be like he'd
be like oh we hired this person as like
just an online editor and like now he's
the director of content cuz we let him
try this other thing or Malory Rubin who
I had worked with before they hired her
as just an online editor and then like
you want to come try to talk on a
podcast and now she's like a brilliant
podcast I was becoming famous in her own
right and I think they you know once he
had people internally give them a little
chance to try different things in a way
that like wouldn't damage anything it
would make them feel empowered and so he
and some of these people have now become
like famous in their own right and and
it seemed like a really happy place and
I think that's part of the reason
because they have a little bit of
ability to try some new things without
having to just leave well because bill
embodies that sensibility like he's done
that in his own career like as he said
on the podcast like he had that you know
he had the show on HBO it didn't work
and yeah but I learned something I moved
on and that informs how I make decisions
about other things going forward to
create that kind of open environment
where people can find their niche over
time yeah that's pretty cool I mean he
seems like I've never met him but he
seems like an awesome guy yeah totally
and really I was just like it was just
interesting how much people like living
there and what they were hired to do and
what they're doing now right because
because Malory I had she had been one of
my colleagues at Sports Hills right and
was like stuck in a very narrow lane so
even for me to now see what she's doing
you're just like she started as like a
copy editor it there so or an editor or
something like that
yeah yeah and and NSI like whatever I
think she was working at Sports
Illustrated for kids whatever was she
was like stuck in a narrow lane
and so to see her now you just like gosh
there must be so much like talent
lurking you know that we just like
haven't given people the chance there's
no question about it and and you know
he's you know in the grand scheme of
things he's running a small organization
like you how do you scale that like if
you look at a fortune 500 company it
becomes calcified over time
where you have some marketing executive
who's reporting to someone else and that
person's decisions are really informed
mostly by you know trying to please
their boss or you know not losing their
jobs so they're gonna like sort of tow
some party line yeah that fits within
the rubric of like how they've always
done it and to step outside of that and
say actually let's stop putting all our
money in billboards like we should be
doing podcast advertising when they've
never done that before is a risk that is
not necessarily encouraged yeah no
totally and and you know I remember it's
reminds me of some of Adam grants work
that show that people actually become
less creative when they become middle
managers yeah it's not like it's just
selecting for they become like much more
much more risk averse I think this is
some of the reason why these larger
organizations can get disrupted by these
tiny animal organizations right because
there's no they have all the resources
antigens and yet they can still get
totally disrupted and so I think you'd
have to take on like try to start with
sort of small groups inside of you know
cuz you can't change the big
organizations are like these oil tankers
you know you have to start steering like
forty miles offshore to get it to the
right place but like I spend some time a
couple years ago with the data analytics
team at UPS which I never would have
thought would be an interesting company
huh but it is interesting because they
because it's brown just because Brown
yeah how its thinking it being around
yeah yeah no I totally it kind of like
yeah brown packages like but but they
face this thing called the Traveling
Salesman problem where it's a math
problem what's the best way to connect a
number of different stops and they you
they used to be like 30 or 40 stops and
with the rise of e-commerce where
they're delivering to a lot more
individuals it's like 120 or 140 stops
and there's more different combinations
of how to connect those stops than there
are like atoms in the universe and
that's not even taking into account
traffic or anything like that
and the fact that they don't like to
take left turns because that's when the
accidents happen always
Thanks and when I went there it's you
know these mathematicians it's run by a
psychologist actually runs the data
science team a psychologist who's just
like interested in data science and
you're there and you're realizing like
they're so they had to make this like
custom mapping and and like routing tool
that the driver then sort of uses and
informs and the driver tries to like
beat it and if the driver beats it then
it like sort of incorporates some of
that but they were telling me like the
algorithm is like the easy part in a lot
of ways the change management is the
hard part because this is a big
organization with a ton of different
levels and a lot of history of doing
things in a certain way so they had
everybody in the data science team had
to work as a driver for a little bit
including the mathematicians the CEO had
worked as a driver also
Wow and so I said that was such a
crucial thing in helping that change
management because suddenly we realized
like just passing down your algorithm
from like you're like bestow it upon
people like make it work was not working
so we actually had to settle for not
quite as optimized of a system but one
that actually worked for what people
were actually doing yeah and so by by
working with these different levels of
the organization I think they realized
sort of where the Cinch in the hose was
and a lot of in a lot of those cases
yeah yeah it's interesting I mean
because theoretically academically like
these ideas that you're talking about
should inform how we reframe corporate
culture right like let's let's allow
people the freedom to move around let's
help them find their place but the human
element of that quickly you you quickly
realize it's it's too disruptive in
order to get anything done yeah right
and and psychology you know gets very
complex in terms of what people's
motivations are here yeah yeah and I
also think if people are working in sort
of those kinder learning environments
where they can face the same challenge
over and over then I think their
interest in their ability still matters
but but the breadth of experience I
don't think matters as much in that case
so it might matter for getting their
match quality but like for industrial
era sort of the stuff when organizations
were very specialized in people faced a
very narrow range of tasks
I think specialization is is fine I just
think we've we've kind of stuck with
that a little too much
yeah but I do think it's changing but
the way that we're seeing it change is
like you said where people are are
cobbling together these careers by
themselves right and is there a way for
you
to shion's to to allow that to happen
internally in a matter a flexible way
yeah that's interesting
or are we just gonna do it like I don't
understand so I mean you know if some
institution had sort of like so you know
would wholeheartedly support me doing a
project like this book I'm sure I would
have done it internal to that
institution uh-huh but I couldn't so I
had to go do it on my own but I sort of
think like there should be places that
would allow that you know yeah but this
is I can't imagine how all-consuming it
was to write this book yeah as much as
you'd be able to actually hold a job and
be productive in that while you were
creating something like this so the book
would have to be like my job right yeah
they would have to what am i reporting
stuff along the way or you know whatever
it is they'd have to view that instead
basically what you do is you go to the
publisher and get like a grant
essentially you know to do to do the
work and then hope that it yeah so I
mean in some respects you work for the
publisher yeah
it is it is yeah if you put a different
lens on yeah yeah you pitch your project
to them uh-huh and if they approve it
then you get the funding in your I do it
yes that's like a very amorphous kind of
kind of job one of the things that you
said to Brad Stolberg and that in the
outside piece was he asked you something
like you know where do you see the
future of you know the professional
environment a camera or exactly what the
question was but you said like I think
the Vanguard right now is seeing the
expansion of these coat these coaching
modalities in the professional world
like taking what we've learned from
sports and applying that to you know the
executive suite to help people not just
be better at like being more productive
but in learning how to like navigate the
psychological landmine of dealing with
people and empowering teams and the like
and you're seeing that with like you
know I used to look at like oh I'm a
coach I'm an executive kind of like what
is that like what kind of nonsense is
that but the more I learn about it and
think about it and read about it the
more I realize like yeah of course why
wouldn't we be doing that yeah and I
think at the higher levels of
performance you know and we both know
this from sports like there's becomes a
point where you can't like tell somebody
what to do at a certain level they have
to like the good coach you know
walks hand-in-hand with them on their
development journey and helps sort of
figure out what's working for them
whether that's a lot of training or
because you can no longer just say like
do it this way right and so I think
that's the part where it's really
analogous where you know sometimes
people get to become executives or even
if they're lower level and then it's
like everyone's a yes-man around them
and all these sorts of things right and
yeah sometimes like their decisions are
very like I got obsessed with war and
peace for a little while and basically
worn pieces like Tolstoy's novel form
argument against the great man theory of
history he says like he uses Napoleon
and says Napoleon was a in effect not a
cause of these like larger movements
going on and he does this historical
reporting that shows like some of the
commands he was issuing could not have
gotten to the battlefield like in time
like the information lag was too long
that like he really had no control over
what was going on I think that can like
executives can become very divorced from
like how their decisions actually play
out or like the kind of chain of
communication to an organization and I
think that's sort of like nobody's
helping them with their development a
lot of times cuz they're just surrounded
by people like who are who trying to
curry their favor ass basically and and
so I think anyone can develop from that
sort of someone who is the outside
observer in their personal development
and is like helping them reflect on
things and identifying some of their own
weaknesses and some of the other
problems and so that was incredibly
powerful thing for me in sports right
and I would love to have it in my other
endeavors yeah I would love to have it
if there was someone you know who would
just you know fair warning to my coaches
I think I told Brad like one of my
favorite editors at SII called me the
athlete who only hears the boos but I
think I've got a lot better at that by
the ones that way explain that it was
just like I would do some project that
would land well and then like the editor
would be like you know and I'd be like
this person's criticism like I'd be like
all fixated on it and yeah that's human
be like you're winning you're winning
don't you know block that out and you
know but I I think it would be I think
I'm better at that now but that's a
warning to my perspective coaches if
anyone hears this and wants to be my
coach but I think it would like I took
in when I got stuck with this book with
structuring because structuring the
information was a real challenge for me
I took an online fiction writing course
that was taught by the author of mud
bound Hillary Jordan
and it's one of the exercises was we had
to write with all dialogue one was with
no dialogue and when doing the no
dialogue when I go back and realize I've
been leaning on quotes to do explanation
in a way I shouldn't been doing I
stripped like probably a hundred quotes
and replace them with writing and the
scary thing to me was I didn't realize
it got me sort of off this plateau and
block and it also sort of made me
realize I was leaning on a certain
technique without even being really
conscious of it and so it would be
really useful for me to have somebody
pointing that sort of thing out that
like you're doing this all the time like
you're leaning on this sort of tactic
all the time and it took me taking that
like a fiction writing class to get sort
of bounced out of that and I'd love to
have it like more consistently yeah it's
interesting you you you I heard you say
like yo you you even take like
introductory writing classes like just
to refresh yourself or ground yourself
in the principles and the fundamentals
and you know it's one thing to be like
generally science writers you know
there's a there's a specific sort of
pros you know methodology that that you
you know that you typically come across
but you have this amazing storytelling
ability that meshes with that that I
think really makes it that book come
alive so whatever you were doing it
worked thanks I really appreciate that
and I think this is another I told you
sort of Frances Hesselbein who's a
character in the book kind of a personal
role model for me so I've can you know
kept up with her because she's very much
like the living embodiment of like
leadership is not what to do but how to
be like just her interactions with
everyone or just like the world would be
a better place you know and she had this
saying you have to well yes she she
learned it from someone else you have to
carry a large basket to bring something
home and this woman when she was at her
first Girl Scout training event and one
of the other you know prospective troop
leaders was saying like I'm not really
learning anything from this it's all so
basic and another woman said to Frances
well you have to carry a big basket to
bring something home which means like if
you keep an open mind you know you'll
get something from it and so like this
sounds kind of funny but recently there
was a you know like a like a Japanese
culture conference at a hotel a couple
blocks away from me like largely based
on sort of anime stuff like that and I
saw oh there's like a beginning like
anime narrative class it's two blocks
away of course I'm going
that you know so you go there and it's
like you know there's only a couple
people there I guess that wasn't the
popular draw for most of people or
whatever but it's like and we're talking
about like what is character and what is
plot and I'm taking notes because I'm
like you always will learn something
from this stuff you know I don't want to
ever get to a point where I think I'm
not a work in progress as a writer ever
well that's a Duckworth growth mindset
okay right there yeah yeah yeah right
I also heard you talk about how learning
how to edit film actually in flow how
you structure your book as well which I
thought was really cool oh that's funny
I don't even know when I last said that
you know where did your homework I don't
know where I came across that but I it's
very apt so yeah wash thought out this
this was so the way this came about was
a friend of mine my name Jeff he was a
film editor and he got some kind of
repetitive stress injury where he wasn't
supposed to like use the mouse a lot
more because his arms were hurting and
so he just talked me through what to do
so you know he was doing all the brain
part and I was just like I owed her
skills and what I realized in doing this
process like getting his basically
documentary was you get all this film
and you cut it up into all these little
chunks right and all and that so that's
like what reporters call your string
right you gather string it's all this
stuff and then you decide which chunks
are gonna keep the rest the stuff hits
the editing room floor and then it's
just a question of how do you order
those chunks basically and so that one
out point feeds into the next end point
and so that's how I started thinking of
structuring my own writing which is just
how do you go from one out point which
is a section break or a chapter breaking
to the next end point so that feels like
especially if you're taking on these
sort of amorphous questions like I did
so that it feels like an escalating
exploration of this question and I
started to become attuned to that in
like some of the masters like someone
like Wes Craven where some of the
material in his films I think is like
patently ridiculous and yet because of
the way he structures it he can often
keep you like maybe I'll come back from
that commercial break even if it's
ridiculous just because of the out point
is interesting and so that's how I think
of structuring my writing is is my
outline is in points and out points for
each section break and then each chapter
and I try to like write between them
right and I noticed by the way just in
some separate reading
I don't remotely I just
disclaimer I don't remotely want to
compare myself to James Joyce on any
level here okay but I read that in some
of his papers were these color coded
sentences that he had and he was like
and he would put them in different
places and just write between like the
color-coded sentences and so to me I was
sort of like maybe similar to this you
right and those are the beats like that
would be the plot beats in a film or you
know that that art of like bringing
somebody right up to the commercial
break with the cliffhanger and knowing
exactly after the commercial how to like
segue into the next section is a version
of you trying to get people to turn the
page yeah engage with the next chapter
and also to try to represent something
of my own intellectual journey as I go
about it because the way I go about it
is sort of here's this question I have
what research can I look for them might
sort of like falsify this or bear on it
and so a little bit and because again
there are no perfect answers to
questions like this my approach is like
can I take the reader along on the
intellectual journey that changed my
mind about some things mm-hmm
and so I try to sort of organize it in
that way - yeah I would think of it
almost more like a documentary that
functions as a narrative the react film
because you're somebody who spends like
an entire year just in the research
phase I can't imagine the volume of
information that you're trying to
collate that's the change and organize
you know so what does that look like are
you putting cards you know up on a wall
and moving them around and trying to
figure out like well where does this
piece and form this and how is this all
gonna work like that just seems
monumental in the sense and in the same
way that a documentary filmmaker who's
got hundreds and hundreds of hours of
you know maybe they've been following
somebody around for years how do you
take all of that and create a story that
moves and has those beats and that
three-act structure it's it's difficult
it's one of the reasons why you know
after my first book my my then agent
said like just don't let it be five
years before you have another book out
and it's been six this is one of those
reasons and it really does live if you
came out the paperback five if you count
the paperback right um yeah but yeah
okay that's good you give yourself a
break yeah
but it really becomes a struggle for me
sometimes like because I'm consuming
things so quickly that sometimes things
start connecting I'm like where did that
go you know I have to find it again and
I have things like laid out very
visually and all this stuff but I do
still on hand or do you do this all
digitally everything everything um but
like one of the ways I'll consume a lot
of papers is I used to go to when I was
in New York I would go to the Columbia
library where I had like alumni reading
access and there were four computers
that were simultaneously logged into
every Journal that the University
subscribes to more than that hyperlinked
in the citations so if you wanted to
bounce right to a citation you could
just do it so I could read tons of
papers like really quickly and I start a
thing I called a master thought list
when I asked my that's my wife before
like how did I because people would
start asking me after my last book how
did you write it and her answer was you
went upstairs and came down two years
later right which is there's some truth
to that but but not helpful yeah so this
master thought list I basically start
putting down stuff that I think is
interesting and that bears on the
question whether that's some quote or
some paper or whatever and as and I try
to tag it with words I think I would
search if I want to come back to it so
this is like a an electronic document
and as those sort of I keep tagging
things with the same words I start
moving those things closer to one
another and when there's a bunch of them
I put like a larger tag above it it's
like this is a topic and then I put a
bunch of words that I think I would
search for that topic and then as and I
call each of those tags and as more the
tags start accumulating then I start
moving like ones closer to each other so
it sort of ends up being like that
storyboarding hmm process kind of yeah
going from a generalization to something
very specialized it also helps with the
citations process yeah yeah I mean I
guess in some ways like yeah that could
that could be like a container that
could fit anything though right yeah
eventually if we say like everything
everything has to become something and
right authorities specialize in whatever
it is so all right well let's uh let's
let's end this with with like some final
thoughts for somebody that is listening
to this and there perhaps stuck in in in
a rut there in their cubicle or there in
their Lane at their job they're not
feeling fulfilled they feel like they
don't have the bandwidth for
you know so much lateral movement how
can somebody kind of engage with you
know aside from my reading the book
which everybody should do like how can
they start to engage some of these ideas
in a way that can help them kind of
shake things up I would say and because
I'm gonna give this advice to myself
right now because I'm not sure what I'm
going to do next is start your little
book of experiments like get it you you
identity doesn't change overnight
so you're if you you know you need a
change right so like there's a
freakonomics study and thereby the
Freakonomics economists that shows
pretty strongly that if people think
they want to change they basically
should by the time you're thinking like
you might want to change already you
clearly should so start that book of
experiments don't worry about like
finding the thing that like lights your
hair on fire you may do that but usually
these kinds of working is part of your
identity and it usually changes a little
piece at a time so reach out to the
fringe of your network take a class in
something you don't know about start
exposing yourself systematically to
little things
having the book of experiments will
force you to reflect on it you know what
did that ignite a new interest it is
it's something that might cater to your
talents and just keep running those
experiments and when you hit on
something where you want to get a little
deeper go ahead and do that but don't
like just that experimentation process
going it doesn't have to be a flying
leap to start learning about yourself
but you do have to be a little
uncomfortable because you're going to
dabble in things that you don't feel as
competent at yeah but get get out of get
to the fringes of your network the
so-called strength of weak ties people
usually get like new jobs from people
who are on the fringe of their network
because they already know the stuff
that's that's sort of closer to the core
of their network but so that's what I'm
doing I'm running i'm using my book of
experiments now and i'm you know pretty
soon where i'm gonna be talking about
this book less i'll be more active in
running some of those experiments uh-huh
it seems like patience is important with
this because I think that that people do
feel like they feel bad because they
haven't been struck by lightning yeah
and they feel this pressure or that
everyone else is having these kinds of
epiphanies that that they're not and
this sense that they've got to figure it
out right away but I think if it's more
of a lifestyle or a mindset to just be
constantly engaging different parts of
your brain and your life experience in
new and different ways there's a trust
that takes over where like you just
you're you're going to be
naturally guided in a direction that
will ultimately lead to different kinds
of opportunities and that chance
encounter that might into this other
thing they can set you on you know a
different path that you just can't see
right now yeah or gives you some
knowledge that you can you can merge
into another domain I mean I would say
if you're not a struck by lightning like
that's okay you know there's no way to
like force that to happen other than
exposing yourself probably some things
and hoping but if over longer time spans
when you're changing what you're doing
if you aren't moving in the direction of
better match quality with those changes
then there's something wrong right then
I don't think you're kind of in that
Dark Horse approach we say who am i
today what are my skills and interests
what are the opportunities in front of
me which will I try and then maybe
you're from now I'll change so you know
over time I think you should be moving
toward that match quality and don't
worry about the lightning like you can't
you can't force that anyway but you can
have this this approach to being a
scientist of yourself that means like
your strategy will move you toward
better match quality in the long term
good stuff man
thanks for having thanks for talking to
me it's my pleasure yeah it's great
range is the book available everywhere
it's almost impossible to miss it I was
in the airport yesterday and there was
like a whole rack like outward facing
like it was the most visible book of
like any book in the in the airport book
store which is a good sign definitely
got out of the gate yester than I
expected crazy man you must be in super
high demand to you know talk at all
these conferences and do all kinds of
stuff and be really out really phasing
right now yeah yeah and I you know and I
obviously want to get the book out there
because I worked hard on it um you know
at the same time I'm like a bit of an
introvert so I need something like the
time to my own and at some point like
I'm kind of a voracious reader and I'm
doing like with the book out I'm doing
like the least reading I've done in
years you know but but no it's great
because well I didn't really think I
didn't know until my last book that
speaking was like a thing that people
would invite me to do uh-huh and I get
very nervous before I do it the same way
I used to do before races no matter how
many times it's just like a race exactly
and I found that I really enjoy it a lot
like I like doing the aesthetics for
like the visual presentations and it's
brought me into contact with all these
people in line
of working walks of life that I would
not have met otherwise and I've actually
totally loved that and totally
unexpected so that's like one area that
just opened up for me that I didn't
expect yeah yeah now you're like this
guy who's speaking all these businessmen
yeah which is super weird because I'm
like you know for a long time just like
what are these like why are they you
know and but but I sort of get it now
that like people are interested in
performance interesting performance they
don't care if it's a chef or a midwife
or a pilot or an athlete or whatever
cool you have any public events that
like if people go to your website if
they want to come and hear you speak or
check you out is that where they should
go yeah
on my web page yeah and I'm also I'm
just a bit I've seen on Twitter and like
what have events coming up I stick them
up there but also David Epstein calm so
they're both easy all right man cool
great to talk to you thank you for
having me I feel good feel great if some
of my favorite people have been in here
so I'm kind of I feel like I'm in a good
call man super super honor to have you
here the book is amazing and once you
finish that read the sports gene as well
and I'll put links up in the show notes
to everything you can go on a super deep
dive into David's world and come back
and talk to me again sometime I would
love to cool base
[Music]